okay
you back i think okay we'll let
everybody show up first yeah
that was weird well yeah what happened
because i think you guys didn't hear but
um we lost power for like a few seconds
and then
the obs the stream went off but then it
like obs said after like five seconds it
said it reconnected and then i saw like
some people had
you know a
comment commented and so i was like oh
maybe it's still going but then tom
tried to go back in and he couldn't find
it i couldn't find the stream a new
stream
and that the first one had stopped so
this is old comments so i was kind of
like okay well i guess we're going to
have to stop and we'll start a new one
because we'll let everybody show up we
only got a couple people in there
okay yeah that was like booked yeah that
wasn't that wasn't that was just a
power flicked out and the yeah and the
uh
modem went off so there's that there's
that well we'll just kind of wait for
about we're about halfway through it
probably i mean a little bit less than
halfway through i mean we've only been
going for like an hour so
okay so we're good
okay everybody's coming in yeah okay
what's up
we gave you guys a heads up we gave you
a warning we told you the storm is
[ __ ] us up
yeah danny rowling's still trying to get
you to put that white wig on you might
have to do it i ain't putting a [ __ ]
white wig on why not why why'd you buy
it then if i put a wig on it's going to
be the danzig wig
[Laughter]
dancing
i just saw your butt crack no i didn't
yeah no i i you can't
you just think anything's cracked you
see that you see that's your favorite
yeah that's a butt crack it's not a
crack that's my back no that's your body
is all the way down here
it's the imagination it's okay
i know what a damn butt crack looks like
it's the top of your butt crack
but yeah
yeah we had the power go out in case you
guys didn't know and i thought that it
came back but i guess it didn't come
back because i guess all the all the
comments like the old comments that had
gone you know and then they come came
back like after the power came back on
so i thought it was still going but
murderhorn said it rarely rains here uh
it was honestly i like rain i mean it's
better than
cooking to death but
usually like i said florida particularly
in the summertime and like the early
autumn is bad like usually like the
afternoon storms are like really really
bad like we get tornadoes and
just [ __ ] like that it's still raining
now but it's not we're not getting like
all the wind and
lightning and [ __ ] like that like we
were getting at least it doesn't usually
last that long that's the thing and then
like i said we get like a bunch of
hurricanes too hurricanes are usually
the worst around september october
sly said we've not had rain since may
2022 holy [ __ ] danny rowling said long
shows are the best shows this is
probably going to be long because
i'm probably only about i'm trying to
look
maybe about a quarter of the way through
my notes or a third of the way like i
said
i know he always kind of like complains
because it's like oh you put too many
cases but it's just kind of like well i
don't know like most of the cases that i
was talking about like weren't that long
so and i wanted to have like a good
i don't know like a good mix of stuff
hugo said people don't know how to drive
here when it rains lots of accidents
yeah same i mean that's why at any time
when it gets raining
the thing about florida though is you
can't really give people like that much
of a thing because most of the people
that live in florida are not from
florida but even people that are from
florida like it seems like every time it
storms they forget
it only does this every [ __ ] day
but
[ __ ] man i've been on the highway like
on i-4 or some [ __ ] like that which is
uh a [ __ ] show even
in the best conditions
but i've been on that where the storm
like a storm blew in like really quick
and it was like so bad that you couldn't
even see like five feet in front of you
like it was just kind of like horizontal
rain and you didn't even and you wanted
to pull over but you were afraid to pull
over because you couldn't see where the
side of the road was anymore like you
couldn't see
you couldn't see like the lines on the
road and you couldn't see the shoulder
and you couldn't see she was just like
well i'm just gonna go like five miles
an hour really really slow and hope
nobody hits me and it's just kind of
that kind of thing because you couldn't
you absolutely could not see a single
[ __ ] thing
but yeah scary
um all right so
are you back over there okay
yeah where else would it be
what do you do why did you breaking [ __ ]
why'd you break her snacky accident
it didn't break
that broke a little fix it
don't be yelling at me
the head came off
well the head's supposed to come off
that's how you put new treats in it is
there still treats in it no
well let me put treats in it then
because otherwise she'll i can't find
any wigs
because otherwise we'll come over here
and sit so i can fix her thing because
you're not worried about it because
you're flopping around everywhere and
you're like messing up don't worry about
it
everybody everybody back i guess so
yeah i got to put
talk or something no
what do you mean no
i don't like talking i'm reading i'm
reading i'm seeing what i was having
when i like entertain people you
entertain me i am entertaining people
i entertain people just all i do is sit
here you're just breaking usually
breaking all pooky's toys
i'll let that sit i'd let that wait
no it's fine
she'll be mad if she comes in no she'll
be mad at me she's got treats everywhere
i know she's got treats everywhere don't
leave this open either
damn man [ __ ] this house is going to
blow over
you hear this [ __ ]
it's a bad storm out there it is well
obviously because the power went out
yeah
all right so she's got her little
snowman filled back up again thank you
jeffy art
i was in the other room when it cut out
last thing i remember was tom being a
minotaur and challenging raider one book
yeah
and then lightning came and
yeah and uh struck us down
thank you for the five dollars and i had
to pull [ __ ] dennis raider out
and uh when i pull dennis reader wrap
money shows up i get some flash bulbs
but you have to understand
dennis is not something that i do
lightly
okay
it's got to be serious for me to pull
dennis out uh-huh it's true
because i got people saying no do dennis
do dennis
i'm not like a performing monkey you
know what i mean i'm talented okay
oh my god i want a shirt that says that
i'm not a performing monkey i'm talented
okay yeah
a channel i'm gonna channel dennis okay
he comes when he's ready okay
i think he tried to strike you with
lightning time yeah he's trying to kill
me he's jealous
he's jealous because you can do his
stick better than him i got a better
butt crack than him
all right way to bring it back around i
like that
i don't want to think about dennis
traders he's just [ __ ] up yeah
that's just sexy
it's all zigzag yeah
this shit's all [ __ ] up allegedly
i don't know i just made it like dennis
right here
he's a little bobble head ass in fact i
can see him i can see him trying to get
me to [ __ ] break dennis
look at his look at his little face
he's he's back there staring at us he's
back there staring at us
well you know you know how it is
tom and jenny just trying to make a show
and uh tom thinks he's channeling me
he's not channeling me i'm [ __ ]
riding on top of him i'm speaking
through
i have all kinds of metaphysical powers
all kinds of [ __ ] supernatural powers
i'm locked up now but
any time i want to give a call to the
outside world i just
i take over i possess tom they [ __ ]
you know what i mean i speak through his
mouth yeah he doesn't know anything
about being the mentor i'm the mentor i
got the ex can we see your butt correct
tom doesn't have a nice butt drag
i got a nice buck can we see it prove it
well i took all kinds of pictures of it
you know
that was back when that was back when i
was in good shape i've been locked up
for a while you know eating hydrox
cookies
[Laughter]
not really getting the kind of exercise
i need and so you know what i mean i'm
not the man that i once was you know no
man to hold together yeah
no back in the day we're not my butt
cracker it was sweating
[Laughter]
girls loved it
girl
okay okay okay girl loved girls loved
his butt crack specifically yeah okay
dennis checked out
he went back to the penitentiary he went
back to the penitentiary he's just
really he's over here
yeah wait that worry out yeah takes
energy from
it grows
it's just it's such a burden for you to
bear time
man has a duty has to do for the show
yeah that's true
all right so you were talking about the
case earlier where somebody like uh
rented a house to somebody and like you
know did the walls out or whatever
this is a case a little bit like that
so this happened in 2013 in
massachusetts
so there was a guy named christian hobbs
and he was 44
and he had basically been living
underneath well i don't know if i'd say
living because he wasn't there that long
he was only there for a few days but he
had been living underneath this woman's
mobile home
and he actually got uh sentenced to
three to six years in prison what ended
up happening
was that there was this woman named um
tina iacono and she lived in salem
and she was 40 years old and she had a
son that was a toddler
now christian hobbs who was the guy who
had sold her the mobile home
one day when she was out
he had come in there and had cut
openings in the floor
and then
he had like this little crawl space like
underneath and he had like a couple baby
monitors under there and a cell phone so
he was just kind of like under there
like recording everything that she did
and some sources said that he had like
asked her out like when she was buying
the house and she's like yeah no thanks
and but he like developed some kind of
obsession with her i don't know if
that's true or not but
he was like underneath her house like
jerking it yeah and like taping her and
like listening to her and her kid who
was like a toddler
um the crazy thing about it is that she
didn't really realize because like i
said it was kind of like it's a trailer
you know it was a mobile home so there's
kind of like a crawl space like
underneath yeah it was a big space
center yeah there's a big space under
there so i i kind of feel like that
wouldn't be that weird because somebody
could probably like come and go into
there without you seeing them or like
you hearing anything skirt in there and
you can [ __ ]
yeah because it's not like in an attic
where you'd hear somebody walking around
like over your head it's like if
somebody was like under the floor you
were like in the car yeah you wouldn't
necessarily like see them
what ended up happening was that he'd
been under there for like a couple of
days
and she was in the bathroom one day i
guess she just like gone to the bathroom
like you do when you go in the bathroom
and she thought she saw something moving
like in there was like a um
like a vent like in the floor
and she saw something like moving around
and she thought it was like an animal
underneath and she looked down in there
and his [ __ ] face was looking back at
her damn she like look can you oh my god
i would [ __ ] [ __ ] a break if that
happened but yeah so she looks down in
there and he looks up at her and like it
like a [ __ ] psycho he just goes hello
damn
that [ __ ] friend i can't even i can't
even so how the hell what was she
looking through
it was like a vent the vent yeah how did
he get inside the [ __ ] air ducts
see i don't really know it seemed like
he pulled off he must have pulled
a piece away so he could look up through
the vent
has to have been
yeah i kind of think that that's what it
was yeah but it's like yeah um he had
actually sold her the mobile home like
five years previously okay yeah and i
guess he decided hey i'm gonna go like
[ __ ] watch her and like wait for her
to get naked so he'd been cutting things
to get through so he could look like
holes and like stuff like that
and so he was and he had like i said he
had a bunch of baby monitors and stuff
and like when the police went under
there
they found when he even admitted yeah
i've been jerking off under there i'm
like great that's really what i want to
hear about like something well they were
going to find that out anyway well i'm
sure yeah because when they looked they
found like a whole bunch of power bars
under there thank you sly thank you yeah
thank you very much thank you sly
yes found a bunch of power bars under
their tissues yeah yeah yeah
lube i
[Laughter]
can you imagine i can't imagine i can
imagine i mean there's not like you know
my bathroom like like i said it's on the
second floor so it doesn't have like a
vent in it but i can't imagine like just
living in a house and like going to the
bathroom like doing your regular [ __ ]
and then like seeing some [ __ ]
like i'm looking at that
like i said it's like a [ __ ] horror
movie yeah jesus christ
yeah so that's what he had done like he
was a handyman and he had sold her the
house so he was just like doing some
[ __ ] around the house he's like hey i'm
gonna hook up some baby monitors in the
trailer and uh cut a bunch of holes in
the floor and like the vent beneath the
bathroom floor ended up causing like 800
in damage like to the house
now
initially
he actually got charged with
manufacturing child pornography because
she had a toddler and obviously the kid
had been naked in the bathroom like
while she was giving him a bath and
stuff like that so they were trying to
like get him on charge of that like so
they could get like some more charges
but um
yeah yeah yeah he was recording it for
later oh are we keeping you awake yeah
we're keeping you awake no i got tired
so he didn't get indicted on that i
guess because they were kind of like
well that maybe wasn't the intent but he
did get um indicted on 10 other charges
so he got um
let's see burglary criminal mischief
attempted violation of privacy uh
attempted interception of
telecommunications or oral communication
so i guess that was like he was
listening in our phone call or something
like that now he and also they found out
too that he also had
a prior conviction like this was several
years before because like i said when he
got arrested this was in 2013 he was 44.
and when he was 18 he'd actually been
convicted before in massachusetts of
larceny and
uh contributing to the delinquency of a
minor like he was a peeping tom he was
like spying on a teenage girl
uh like getting naked or whatever how is
that contributing to her dealing with
she see that's what i don't know she's
been in on it that's what i mean i don't
well or i don't know if they didn't have
a law in the books back then that was
like for peepingtown i don't really know
what the deal was
he said he told police he's like oh well
i have a voyeur problem and he needs
like counseling he must have been giving
her alcohol or something in exchange for
it something like that maybe that's
contributing to delinquency usually
involves an adult buying alcohol buying
alcohol or giving something that to a
kid that they're not old enough to have
that
so she might he might have been she
might have been trading with him
yeah you can look at me if you give me a
six-pack that kind of weird [ __ ]
yeah
that's that's [ __ ] up yeah it's [ __ ]
up that's minor chat when you compare to
well i know that but i'm just saying the
main [ __ ] in the main
stream of [ __ ] crime you know what i
mean well yeah a lot of worse well like
i said it's what if i say something's
[ __ ] up that doesn't mean that other
things aren't also [ __ ] up it's this
whole spectrum of [ __ ] up yes
yeah you know what i mean yeah that's
low down all the time but it's still
[ __ ] up but it's still [ __ ] up
so he had to go to like a sex offender
treatment program uh and i guess they
had like uh you know they had a
restraining order or whatever but i
don't know if he's still in prison
though because i think the the maximum
was six years and that was 2013 so even
if he got the maximum he would have been
out by now so i don't know i couldn't
find anything else about him so maybe
he's been behaving himself i don't
really know
so here's another one
so i think this might have happened in
the uk actually yeah this is a uk one
like i said all the other ones i think
are united states but this one's uk
so there was this uh this happened in
2015.
so there was a woman named marie wright
now she was 28 and she was dating this
guy named alexander cooper who was 27.
now they have been dating for about five
months so like i said this was 2015.
what ended up happening is they had
actually met like 10 years prior but had
kind of like lost track of one another
but then
they both uh one of them like saw the
other one on plenty of fish that uh you
know that dating website or dating app
or whatever
there it is well it's still around but
yeah i think but um but yeah
so they started like oh yeah i remember
that [ __ ] or whatever so they
kind of like reconnected and started
dating again
she says
he seemed totally totally normal don't
they all at first
uh so yeah so they start dating um
but what ended up happening
about five months into the relationship
she asks alexander to stay with her at
her home which was in sheffield she's
like hey um you know my roommate is away
like on vacation
um so just either stay you can stay in
the house with me like and while they're
gone so i don't have to say by myself
so he does that but then like after that
she's like okay like go back to your own
house now she's like i kind of need my
own my space or whatever
um he's like okay yeah that's fine i'm
gonna go uh stay with my dad for a
little while
but um spoiler alert you know what the
show's about he didn't do that he didn't
go live with his dad
so
uh her roommate marie's roommate comes
back from vacation and then they start
noticing weird little [ __ ] around the
house like uh food's missing from the
freezer
um
toilet paper is getting used like way
faster than
normal
um
[Music]
you know they're kind of like losing
track of like where our cigarettes i
bought a whole pack and now it's gone
[ __ ] like that
so
now initially they were just kind of
like you [ __ ] you did that no you [ __ ]
you did that i didn't do it you know
what i mean because you think it's like
the other person
um
so they started doing stuff like they
started setting like little booby traps
from one another right like putting tape
on the cab on the cabinet doors and
stuff
um now they found out like while they
were at work like somebody has been like
[ __ ] up with the tape and it's just
kind of like and then they found like i
guess they had like this attic loft or
something and they found there was all
kind of like dirty fingerprints all over
and they're like okay well we know
neither one of us did that so then they
called the cops
now the cops come
but the cops were super not helpful they
basically they're like they didn't they
went up into the loft but they didn't go
into the back of the loft because i
guess it was a big boiler in the way and
they didn't like look behind it or
anything they just kind of like glanced
up there and we're just like yeah
there's nobody maybe change your lock so
bye you know what i mean it was that
kind of thing
now she here's the [ __ ] up thing so
she tells she's still dating
alexander at this point
and she says
to alexander holy [ __ ] i think
somebody's like living in our house
and he even goes up there with a
flashlight into the attic like looking
around nope nobody up here
the uh the [ __ ] audacity
and he was the guy that was doing it
yeah but she didn't know that so it's
like so
yeah so he's acting like all like all
chivalrous and everything all go up
there and check for you nope nope
nobody's up here you're fine it's just
that kind of [ __ ] yeah he had a crowbar
and everything like he was gonna like
hit the guy i'm just like jesus christ
[ __ ] hell
uh now the next day after that happened
marie saw that somebody had taken out
three payday loans
worth 450 pounds out in her name
and had taken 200 pounds in cash out of
her
checking account
now she was like okay that had to be
like what whoever the [ __ ] is
that's living up in the loft because
maybe like while i was sleeping they
came down and like took my card or
something like that so she tells the
cops they took statements
and while she's telling the cops her
boyfriend alexander is right there being
all supportive and stuff
now her housemate though has twigged
onto the fact i don't really trust this
alexander [ __ ]
so
while uh marie was taking alexander like
to his father's house the next day
she called her brother and said go up in
the attic and see what the [ __ ] is going
on up there
so the brother goes up there and they
find this whole makeshift bedroom like
the dude like the pictures of it look
really squalid it's just kind of like it
doesn't even look like he had real i
couldn't really tell from the picture
but it looked like he was using like
shitty old like insulation like for
blankets it didn't look like he had like
a real blanket or nothing maybe he did
but and it was just dirty i don't know i
couldn't tell but it looked like shitty
old insulation
but
the roommate says
he had been texting me from up there
telling me he couldn't answer phone
calls because his phone was broken
actually it was because he was in the
loft he didn't want to like answer calls
because he's like he thought that
someone would hear him right
uh and she then she said it was like
survivor up in the loft he had made a
bed out of quilts and our blankets and
pillows off the settee which is like the
couch it was so weird there were food
wrappers and um there's like cigarette
ashes everywhere and she said i found a
stash of his dirty clothes hidden in my
room they had been there so long they
smelled bad there was also a stanley
knife like a big knife so he had had he
was keeping his dirty clothes like in
the roommate's bedroom and they stunk
and it was just he'd been living up
there like all this time he couldn't
wash his clothes i guess i guess yeah so
at this point yeah she's just like hey
your stupid boyfriend has been like
living up in this in our [ __ ] attic
and like pretending that i can't
the [ __ ]
cheek the [ __ ] nerve of the guy to
like just be i'll go up there like oh
yeah that's that's so terrible blah blah
blah oh my god [ __ ] got forced into a
situation [ __ ] off dude oh my god he got
forced into a situation seriously
so they call the cops again and they're
like look it was her boyfriend the whole
time
um and he admitted he's like yeah i used
her bank card and like i took out
because he stole a bunch of money from
mercy yeah and then this is so sad to me
but it's just like um marie says this is
a quote that was in the paper it felt
like it was all my fault because i
trusted him and he was my boyfriend even
though i know it wasn't i'm like is that
sad that she like blades how the [ __ ]
would she know she wouldn't know
you don't know some motherfucker's gonna
do some [ __ ] like that so he got put in
jail for 16 months so he played 16
months 16 months that's a long time yeah
yeah he pled guilty to what was 12
counts fraud theft
uh perverting the course of justice
i guess because he had like pretended
that you know something that there
wasn't anything going on or something
like that so yeah he got 16 months out
of the deal i don't know what happened
to him after that because that was like
2015 but apparently he is not reoffended
because i didn't see his name come up
any newer than that so you know
now here's another case sounds like he
was just in a particular situation where
he could do that
and that was he got pushed into doing
that
type of crime and you know what i mean
hiding in a girl's house he was dating
her
so yeah he he didn't have his own house
so he had to figure out how he's going
to live with her so he lived up yeah
yeah
i mean he didn't have any money to have
a pot to piss until he started stealing
from her yeah
and another sad thing too was that she
said you know if he needed money he
could have asked me but i was just like
yeah but if you knew he was living in
the attic you wouldn't have like given
him any
like get the [ __ ] out of my attic that's
why he didn't say anything i guess he's
like oh she'll dump me she finds that i
don't have a pot to piss in
it's like he's hiding up in the house
surprised she dumped you anyway because
you're living in her [ __ ] attic yeah
you got 16 months and stealing money
good job bud right i mean what the [ __ ]
were you saying man a place to live man
i'm [ __ ] homeless let me sleep on
your couch
you know that's what i mean so much
would have been avoided if he would have
just said hey like just been honest and
said look i'm broke and i don't have any
place to live like she might have been i
mean she might have just said oh well
not your problem not my problem but it's
like you know maybe she would have said
oh you can sleep on our couch until you
figure something else will help a guy
she likes that's what i'm saying like if
you're dating them i need a job and i
need money and i need to get a place to
live you know can you help me [ __ ] a
lot of women will help you i mean too
yeah i mean up to a point like you can't
just like
yeah i mean as long as you're not being
a dick about it or something like that
it's like yeah a lot of them actually
will help you out so it's just kind of
like
you know i wouldn't have minded if like
if he had just said that i'd been like
yeah you can sleep on my couch for a few
weeks until you like find something else
like someplace else
or something like that
i wouldn't it takes more than a few
weeks more like a few months well yeah
but i'm just saying that like until you
like find a better situation
[ __ ] roommate you know it's just
kind of like why the [ __ ] yeah but the
fact that he went that route
just you know that i don't know and then
and then had the audacity to like
pretend like
he wasn't living up there and like he's
oh oh no honey somebody's like living up
in your house i'll check that out i'll
figure it out
[ __ ] off with that jesus christ dude all
right so here's another [ __ ]
that moved into his ex-girlfriend's
house so it seems to be it seems to be a
recurring theme they're not all like
well you know her so you might as well
move in with her
[Laughter]
sleep inside your walls pretty much yeah
i'll creep out and get a blanket
that's what they're doing
that's [ __ ] funny i mean [ __ ] man
yeah
so this this one happened in uh 2012.
and this actually happened in rock hill
south carolina and uh the girl's name
was uh tracy she actually didn't want
her last name said so it always says
last name withheld but her name is tracy
and uh so she had five kids was a single
mother
now she's in a house she lives in a
house
and she said the first thing she noticed
in 2012 was that
she started hearing like this thumping
noise from up above her like her bedroom
and then she sees nails start popping
out from the bedroom ceiling and this is
like 2 2 30 in the morning
now initially like we said she thought
it was poltergeist activity like what
the holy [ __ ] nail comes down like nails
are like popping out of the ceiling like
that
now
she's like okay well there's all these
weird noises up there so she sends one a
couple of her older sons up there like
go check and see what that is
now the suns go up there and they find
out that some of the nails have been
like kind of pride loose from the
floorboards
and when they went up there they found
like inside of the heating unit
they found like a 44 year old guy who
was sleeping
and he had like gone inside the heating
unit i guess and it like put all these
juggers it was cold there or whatever
but it's like um south carolina to get
that cold does it i don't know but it's
like so he'd put jackets all inside
there yeah it must be winter time so you
put jackets all inside there was like
sleeping in there and so like the suns
were like um hey [ __ ]
why are you sleeping in my mom's attic
like in the heating thing in the middle
of the night
and it turned out that this dude was
tracy's ex-boyfriend
who she had broken up with
12 years previously damn 12 years
previously you knew where her house was
this [ __ ] dude man yeah now the thing
about it and the reason why she had
broken up with him 12 [ __ ] years ago
was that he was a criminal uh he'd
actually kind of like beaten up on her
in the past he had stolen her truck at
which point she's like get the [ __ ] out
um and he actually ended up in prison
now he would write letters to her from
jail but she either didn't answer or
wrote back and was like [ __ ] off and die
you [ __ ]
you know i'm paraphrasing
um
but she just kept saying look you know
we're not a thing just like stop writing
to me
but evidently shortly after he was
released from prison he found out where
she lived uh and snuck into her house
and climbed up in the attic
and
he was uh you know just like this other
[ __ ] guy not only was he sleeping up
in her attic but he'd also like uh kind
of drilled some holes and stuff like
that so he could look into her bedroom
at night so he could watch what she was
doing
um you know so there was that
now once he was uh once they found him
uh he [ __ ] took off
now basically police the police came and
they investigated the attic they found
like a whole bunch of evidence obviously
they didn't actually know how long he
had been in there
um
but they knew that he must have come in
because they said the only way that you
could get up there was there was this
hallway that kind of like went like
between a bunch of the bedrooms that was
like the only way you could get in there
so he must have been going in and out
like when nobody was home or somebody
would have seen him
now the scary thing about this is that
because he took off they looked for him
but they were never able to find him so
i don't know
like i looked to see if there was any
kind of like recent updates on this kind
of case but on this case but i didn't
see one so i don't know if they ever
caught the dude like the the one the um
article that i found from 2012 it
basically described the dude and said he
was still at large but i looked to see
if there was anything more recent and
there really wasn't they said i don't
think they ever did find the dude
and they said that um her and her kids
were like freaking out because they said
holy [ __ ] if you found us before then he
could easily find us again and if they
don't catch him like we don't know he
must have moved on i mean i would hope
well yeah but she would think that but
like you break up with a [ __ ]
and then like 12 years later he turns up
like living in your house i mean
obviously that's a dude that's like um
carrying a torch or something well he
was in prison for most of that though
right
i don't know how long he was in prison
actually i don't know if he was in
prison that whole time right but he must
have been in prison for a long time and
then he needed a place to go so he went
to go look for her
that's weird though you'd think he'd be
like on uh
going through halfway houses and
probation and everything
and they were you you'd think that they
would want to know if he was working
he was totally free
somehow and he looked for her
yeah weird
and i don't know if she was living in
the same house that she lived in like
when they broke up and that's how he
found her or if he found her some other
way he felt comfortable up there because
he knew who she was
and also he wanted to keep an eye on him
yeah it seemed like he was one of those
not forever though he and then he split
i don't know i don't i don't know if i'd
ever be able to like sleep right at
night after that
you know what i'm saying he's gone he's
gone yeah but like i said she probably
thought that before too and then like 12
years later here's this [ __ ]
again
here's what she wasn't here
she wasn't alert to the fact that this
[ __ ]
was around
now that she is he's probably not he
yeah he's gone
yeah hopefully she like bought a gun or
something he probably got something
better in life and then moved on or he's
back in jail but no they said they never
caught him
so i mean but he might have gone to
somewhere yeah i didn't see anything
that he'd been caught but like i said i
don't know what his name was either
because they kept um
all the articles about it like she
didn't want her identity known so it was
kind of hard to like look because i
didn't know what the dude's name was so
it's very very possible that he could
have got caught for some other [ __ ] and
like whatever it was he didn't have
anywhere to go
he considered her home
weird huh i guess yeah that's how it is
i mean
that's how he thought i don't even
remember [ __ ] that happened 12 years ago
much less jesus christ man
he considered
her as as like his next akin
i guess
yeah you're gonna go live in your
[ __ ] hand yeah i'm gonna live in your
attic because you don't like me but i'm
gonna live in your head
and then i'll figure this [ __ ] out
jesus christ these [ __ ] people all
right so the next one i want to talk
about this happened back in 2008
and this is [ __ ] up this happened like
right around christmas time
so there's this woman named stacy
ferentz and she had three kids and they
lived in uh plains township in
wilkes-barre pennsylvania
now around christmas time like i said of
2008 they started like you know kind of
your regular stuff like we've been
talking about like the hearing weird
sounds food disappearing from the fridge
like stuff going missing like their
belongings and stuff
um this went on for about a week
and at first like i said they didn't
really think anything about it and this
i kind of this kind of resonated because
they were like well we had a bunch of
cats so anytime we like heard noises in
the middle of the night we just figured
it was the cats which is usually what i
do too that's why like if somebody broke
in the house we'd be like
it'd probably be bad because i would
wake up and be like what is that noise
oh it's pokey because pookie makes all
kind of noise like in the light running
up and down the hall and stuff so
people that have cats they make noise at
night you know they're nocturnal no one
could fool me if there was a man-sized
[ __ ] creature in this second house
i'd know it i mean yeah you do have to
think like we're pretty familiar with
all the noises that pookie makes yeah i
mean she's loud like for being really
small but you would hope that it would
sound completely different if it was
like somebody walking around i would
think yep
but yeah so but they didn't really think
anything of it like i said it must not
have been anything too egregious like
the sounds because they just thought it
was their cats
now one of the things that uh stacy the
mom remembers she said her daughter
courtney
uh woke her up like really really early
like a few days before christmas and
said there's somebody in my closet and
the closet was where the the uh you know
the
the panel for the attic was just like in
this closet right here
and the mom was just kind of like she
just thought she was having a bad dream
that's what see sometimes like when you
see the show of haunting they're just
like oh there's nobody in your closet
every now and then there actually might
be because in this case there actually
was somebody in there but the mom didn't
actually look because she was like oh
you just had a bad dream it's fine
um
so but then she started noticing like a
bunch of their clothes were missing um
it was around christmas time so some
other relatives that like sent them cash
and christmas cards and a bunch of was
missing uh her daughter just got a new
ipod that was also missing and a bunch
of like gifts and stuff
um and they said on christmas day
it seemed like their house actually got
robbed twice like a bunch of their [ __ ]
like disappeared in the morning and then
like a bunch more of their [ __ ]
including stacy's new laptop
uh got stolen like later on that evening
she's like okay something is [ __ ]
going on and she also found like a dirty
footprint
leading up to the attic and she's like
okay well there's must be some
[ __ ] in here so she calls the
cops so the cops come
and they find a dude named 20 uh like
stan his name was stanley carter he was
21 years old
now he actually uh surrendered without
any uh fuss or anything like that on the
day after christmas what ended up
happening was that i guess the house was
a duplex
and he had been living with his friends
next door
and they kicked him out
and so he went up into the attic and
then crawled across the attic to the
other house and then had been coming
down into their house and like stealing
their [ __ ] they said when they
this is like crazy but they said when
they first like caught him and they
brought him down from the attic like
when the cops came
he had on the daughter's pants
and the mom's sweatshirt and sneakers
that's all i could find
yeah yeah i don't think he was just like
the like oh i'm into like wearing their
clothes or anything i think it was just
like the clothes that he just took stole
from the laundry and like that was what
fit yeah um so yeah so stacy said from
what i gather yeah i guess so he was
helping himself to my home eating my
food and stealing my clothes
and she this was the weirdest thing
it says she even found a piece of paper
in the attic where he was writing down
every item that he'd stolen from them
and across the top of it it said
stanley's christmas list
who does that i don't know who does that
so yeah
he was actually i guess he was
originally from arkansas like i said so
yeah he had been living in the house
next door like which was attached and
they had told him to move out i don't
know why um so he climbed up through a
trapdoor and just like he'd been living
there for about a week and the crazy
thing is that after his roommates like
kicked him out for whatever reason i
don't know what it was
but they didn't know where he went after
that and they were so worried about him
that they actually reported him missing
on december 21st because they said well
we kicked him out but then we don't know
what happened to him afterward what
happened was that he crawled up into the
[ __ ] attic and then was living in the
house next door like without anybody
knowing but like his friends actually
did report him missing i need him where
to go i guess not so it's just kind of
like yeah so the laptop that he stole
from stacy
the police actually like took it and
he'd been like writing emails to people
on it and they said one of the emails
said i don't want to go back to jail i'd
rather be wanted
so that kind of suggests that he
probably has a criminal record though i
don't know what what it's for
um so he actually got they charged him
with like burglary receiving stolen
property theft criminal trespassing um
and then he had to go back to this
prison that he depended so i'm assuming
i don't know what the charge was before
but i guess he had been like
incarcerated before so i don't really
know
but um i don't know i i guess that his
uh his attorney said oh he feels really
bad about it and he wasn't hurting
anybody i was like yeah but he stole a
bunch of their [ __ ] though i mean that's
not cool trying to survive i get well
you don't need an ipod to survive okay
and like you wanted to communicate
so
um so i don't know so i don't know if
he's been arrested anywhere else
but
yeah so he didn't like hurt anybody but
he did like steal a bunch of stuff
so i think i have a couple more cases
but the last one is like the worst one
so that's why i wanted to save that
until last but this i mean this one's
kind of bad too but it's just kind of
like um
the second to the last yeah i think so
like the last one is like the worst ones
that's why yeah the last one's the worst
one so that's why i wanted to like save
it so this one actually happened fairly
recently this happened in september of
2019 don't forget to give us a thumbs up
people we need to like it like the video
please yeah like yeah it's it does
actually like make uh it makes a
difference in [ __ ] we lost the first
stream and we had a lot of likes on that
one
all right so we're i'm still on my first
drink i guess yeah it was strong though
was it yeah it was strong that was like
a triple doesn't it seem like i mean
it's all watered down now but
want more yeah i wouldn't mind another
one and more like more ice and like more
okay you know what i mean
all right so this happened in september
2019.
so you got james and brittany campbell
and they had been on vacation for a week
and they come back home at the end of
their vacation now they lived in
honolulu in hawaii
so they come back home to their house
and
immediately they go to open the door
and there's a dude like peeking out
through their door like when they open
it
and the guy's like trying to hold the
door shut
and they're like
bro what the [ __ ]
and the man says to james this is not
your house
i'm like
i beg to differ but okay yeah he was
like trying to hold the [ __ ] door
shut and the guy said uh james like the
guy whose house it was he's like the guy
just was very calm this is not your
house and he just like peeks out holy
[ __ ]
so uh they call the cops obviously
and this guy his name is uh ezekiel zeus
i think i'm pronouncing that sort of
correctly
and they open it up he's in there and
he's been wearing james's he's wearing
james's clothes like when they arrest
him right
now when they go inside the house
uh like i said the campbells have been
gone for a week
they go inside the house and the house
is trashed
there are
the the article said bodily fluids
covered the furniture okay well okay
so use your imagination
well could be could be lots of bodily
fluids i mean you know what i mean but
probably
um they this is funny too the article
also said this is a quote the kitchen
was filled with strange concoctions
what the [ __ ] does that mean
meaning they he was mixing some stuff in
there i don't know what the [ __ ] he was
making was he making some weird-ass
smoothies oh spooge smoothies
maybe that's why there was fluids out
don't write anything i don't know i mean
strange concoctions i don't know if that
that doesn't necessarily whenever you
say concoctions i usually think of like
a drink like because that conjures up
like which witch's brew or something but
that could be food too i mean he could
have been like cooking stuff said well
that didn't work out
um
but they he pretty much like trashed
everything he took like all their stuff
and just like broke it and threw it
around and destroyed it
and they also found like a bunch of
stuff that he had written
about the couple
like he
wrote that he was going to
like lay them out and like perform
surgery on them
and like he had laid out like a bunch of
knives like he was a surgeon and he was
going to like do some kind of
yeah like he was playing and all kind of
[ __ ]
um
he only mentioned something if it was
was was the ipad ipod really stolen if
it was still in the house
that's the thing
is that yeah see that's like a
technicality well the thing about it is
that
i mean technically i guess it's still
stolen because look if somebody
they're still in the house though
yeah but i mean okay but okay let's
imagine a hypothetical situation where
i live in a
an apartment like with a roommate yeah
and the roommate comes in my room while
i'm not there and takes my [ __ ] and puts
it in her room right that's still
technically stealing because you took it
from me even though i mean it's still in
the same house but i don't know where
the [ __ ] it's at you took it okay and
you didn't have permission okay so i'm
kind of thinking
and if and they didn't know they didn't
have any way of knowing if like if the
person was still in the house or not i
don't think it matters if they're still
in the house i don't think proximity is
like a but that's an interesting point
now that you bring i never really
thought about it that way
this person in proximity has something
to do with like whether it's like
[ __ ] stolen or not
it's like it can't be stolen i only
moved it five feet but yeah you know it
was right there but yeah
so yeah so this guy ezekiel
not only had he said had he fantasized
and written down like all these plans
and laid all these knives like i'm gonna
do surgery on the [ __ ] people that
live in this house for whatever reason
um but he also had like all these diary
entries like really really detailed that
he had written about them which led
police to believe that he had probably
been i don't know if he'd been living in
the house the whole time but he for sure
had been like watching them very very
closely so they thought well he at least
must have been
either in the house or
having access to their [ __ ] and like
watching what they were doing
and when the cops said that
the couple was like oh my god like even
before we went on vacation they
remembered some weird [ __ ] happening in
the house like sometimes their webcams
would come on in the middle of the night
or you know they would think that they'd
lock the doors but they were unlocked
and stuff like that so they don't
actually know how long that dude had
been in there before they went on
vacation now they actually they actually
also found some videos that like the guy
had made like on the webcams and stuff
like that like the guy would like
take all his clothes off and like sit in
their chairs and like do [ __ ] up [ __ ]
like that
so
like i said they don't know how long
he'd been in there it'd have been at
least a week but it was probably longer
because when they brought it up so he
had probably been living in there like
before they even went on vacation like
and they didn't realize it but then like
when they went on vacation he just like
went out and started like trashing the
police
so they got a restraining order against
him
um and he got arrested
now he gets taken into custody and he
was let out on supervised release for a
little while but then he gets arrested
again
um for this incident that happened at
the buddhist study center in manoa
hawaii
um so he got arrested again so then
they take him back to prison in
august like late august of 2020
and
then he gets in a fight with another
inmate
it wasn't even a fight he just basically
ezekiel the guy that had been living in
this in these people's house he starts
punching this other inmate named vance
grace in the head like multiple times
like over and over and over he just
starts hitting him and hitting me and
him in the head vance like falls on the
ground and then ezekiel just like kept
stomping his head and like the guards
came and like told him to stop
but he wouldn't do it he just like kept
it he was just like stomping and
stopping and stopping now eventually
like a bunch of the guards came and like
jumped on him and like restrained him
but uh vance was killed so he he had
like a hematoma
so ezekiel uh who was then 27 years old
he got charged with first and second
degree murder
so
yeah that's [ __ ] great so this dude
that later like beat another prisoner to
death was living in these people's
houses and like
pooped and spooched on all their
furniture and said he was gonna like cut
them all open and yeah had probably been
living in the house
prior to that and like turning on their
webcams and [ __ ] like that so that's
nice
sleep tight you guys
nice uh it is pretty nasty so this is
the last case and this is the one that's
the most uh complex and this is like the
worst one all right this is like the
worst so this is the capital case the
crowning achievement yeah this is what i
said
living in your house i definitely wanted
to this is [ __ ] up and the thing about
it is like they
have
have they made a horror movie about this
if they made a horror movie about this
i'm not sure anyone would believe it
intruder was kind of a case of frogging
well yeah that's what i was thinking
and i was gonna meet the house yeah
that's exactly well that's exactly what
it's scamming on that hot ass black
chick what was her [ __ ] name again
and the husband there was like what the
[ __ ] he'd pop out dennis [ __ ] quaid
[ __ ] with his mouth going
like going here
with that big [ __ ] french smile that
he had it was one of the best b movies
we saw the theater then i recommended
that it was somebody one a regular
viewer much remember which one it was
went and saw it because yeah yeah it was
kind of cool but it was like some awful
lifetime but it was just well like i
said people are sick of those kind of
movies now they've been done over and
over again but [ __ ] you know i'm
looking at from the point of view of an
old [ __ ] who's looking at it
retro like you know i mean i haven't
seen something like that all in a while
it just kind of reminds me like
kind of like [ __ ] cape fear or what
was wrong with the dude [ __ ] living
in the damn house and [ __ ] letting
the roaches go is that pacific heights
specific heights yeah something like
that i kind of want to see that again
yeah
we should do we should do like a whole
month where we just talk about like
[ __ ] yeah 90s thrillers like that
like pacific heights and yeah what i
liked about it i liked about it
what i liked about intruders it's
happening in upper middle classville
[ __ ] nice house you know it's kind of
like a house there's a house bigger than
this one and more a little bit more old
school it's kind of like a [ __ ] kind
of like a southern plantation style
mansion
if you're gonna had that damn black
couple in there and the [ __ ] bad guy
was a white dude living underneath the
[ __ ] ground it was a good angle it's
a good angle scoping on a black girl
it was i could it was made to terrorize
black people [ __ ] sly you got to see
that flick man you'd [ __ ] like it
[ __ ] it yeah it's good it's like i don't
want anybody living underneath my house
i don't care what color they are yeah
the lesson of that story is white man
gonna get your woman that's [ __ ]
i was [ __ ] laughing through the whole
thing but the thing is what sucked about
it is that [ __ ] when me and jenny
were watching that at amc we were like
the only people in the theater
well like i said i can understand that
it's like i mean the the heyday for
those type of movies was kind of like
the 90s the 90s right i kind of feel
like in the 90s it was like a billion
movies like that and like people were
really into them they got like big
[ __ ] it was a throwback movie it was
very thrilling
like nowadays they make a lot of movies
like that still but usually they're like
you know tv movies they're like lifetime
movies or something like that yeah and
and uh it was intruder it's called
intruders it's called intruder
dennis quinn
dennis quaid came out a couple years
back and had that [ __ ] black dude
with the glasses he's always playing
intellectual guy in it i thought
wasn't he in the jacob's ladder remake i
want to say i think it was the same
actor but it's been a while since i've
seen either one of those but i thought
that it was the same guy that was in the
jacob's ladder remake but you know
[ __ ] i'm very attuned to to
entertainment and psychology and [ __ ]
it was definitely designed to [ __ ]
scare black people it was like for a
black audience
but it worked man [ __ ] i was white
guys watching it and i was going yeah
yeah yeah they were doing all kinds of
psychological
[ __ ]
games uh and it was intended to [ __ ]
scare the [ __ ] out of a black audience
[ __ ] creepy [ __ ] white man [ __ ]
living underneath your [ __ ] house
coming after you a young hot black wife
well i mean it creeps me out too yeah it
was creepy it was creepy
but
they had it [ __ ] they had it
it was
kind of [ __ ]
i don't want to say it was not black
product i don't think black people made
that movie
uh but it was it was intended for a
black audience i believe it was a good
movie though i liked it
i mean spooky like i said it was over
the top but in in the fun way like a lot
of the lifetime movie yeah yeah it was
fun it was fun you know you don't take
it seriously you just enjoy it they're
they're they're they're playing games
with you when they make this kind of but
anyway i want to see that one again
actually that's one i would own
and in that way well like i said it was
a lot of fun yeah a lot of people were
like well you would buy that you said
yeah i would i'd buy that movie
i just liked it
and we watched years of movies at amc
and that's still one of them that kind
of stuck out
yeah well as i said because it was a
little bit i don't want to say it was
like an anachronism but it was
one they don't really make them like
that that play in the theater anymore
and dennis quaid [ __ ] just chewed up
the scenery
over the [ __ ] top well he knew that
that was what was required yeah over the
[ __ ] that's what that's what made it
good yeah
but yeah it was definitely like one of
those cheesy ass lifetime movies like
mother may i flirt with danger or
whatever the [ __ ] that one was called
fear or [ __ ] well
kate fear was a lot better keep yours a
lot better but it was like it was like a
90s movie
yeah
i'm not going to bid a little bit little
it yeah [ __ ] um
uh lifetime does make a lot of [ __ ] like
that and i understand what you're
talking about it was better than that i
think
i think it was better it had probably
probably a bigger budget it had a bigger
budget and if it had good acting it was
just like a weird movie we mentioned it
a couple times and speak
listeners went back and watched it was
like yeah okay i see we're talking about
yeah yeah it's just it's just fun
yeah just fun it's not like meant to be
taken yeah yeah
yeah he goes that's right
yeah
what's called an intruder see it slice
you'd like a slide
okay he's talking about what about i
said the intruder with hillary swank uh
when a young doctor suspects she may not
be alone in her new brooklyn lobby she
learns that her landlord is ooh yeah
that's they see there's another one like
yeah yeah
that's not the one we're talking about
we're talking about intruder i know but
he's saying that that's another one yeah
at the same price with dennis quaid
okay check that one out
that was almost kind of like a florida
movie it looked like that was taking
place in florida that looked like dr
matt's house
i don't know where it was i didn't think
it was florida but no it wasn't florida
but it looked like dr matt's house
yeah
camp guy said uh when i was talking
about the guy like uh spoojing all over
the furniture yeah camp guy said i would
have to move to a totally new house and
buy new furniture yeah yeah i mean i
probably would too i mean i would just
like keep thinking about it yeah zach
zach you showed up bro i thought i had i
thought i had lost my [ __ ] gay
following
i was talking about you earlier on in
the show
his ears were burning though yeah years
are burning up gonna show up yeah
i thought i lost my gay fan base
[Laughter]
i'm [ __ ] with you bro
oh my god yeah
uh yeah we should probably do cape fear
at some point yeah i mean i've seen it a
long time i looked it up the other day i
mean you can't watch it it's not free
though you gotta do it but it's only
like 3.99 i haven't seen a long time i
remember loving it yeah i thought it was
great yeah but like i said that was back
when what's his name was good
yeah
he's not any good anymore that's like
the last gangster movie anymore hey
[ __ ] soy
what's his name which one rob de niro
which one do you think robert de niro
kind of [ __ ] over the movie are you
talking about uh that last uh where he
played where he played uh that last
gangster movie that he was in what the
irishman i think was called the irishman
i liked the irish it was the thing is he
was too old for the role and they did
the thing they just man i ain't gonna
talk about it
i don't want to talk about it when he
was stomping that other dude in the
ground you could tell why didn't he get
a body double you could tell that was an
old man
doing that it's just ridiculous
but that was the only thing that
bothered me about yeah i mean other than
that yeah that just kind of blew the
whole thing
for me i was just like man and and other
than that it was a good movie
pretty good
but
that era is over with
unfortunately it's just the way it is
the the gangster move the italian extra
movies are coming to an end
well i mean not until a new [ __ ]
they made so many of them they made a
lot of them but you need a new director
and it's got to come back in
television series is the way to go now
all right so let's talk about this one
case and then you can talk about
whatever you want okay
so this is the case of daniel laplante
now this [ __ ] like i said this sounds
like a [ __ ] horror movie now
i don't know now i'm gonna say right
here i'm you know i got this from like
several sources but i don't know like
how much of this has become something of
like an urban legend over time and like
details have been exaggerated not really
sure because this happened like back in
86 87 so it could be that
you know it's kind of gotten some urban
legend
type uh
things going on with it but i don't know
so daniel laplante he was a guy um a
couple years older than me so he was
born in 1970 in townsend massachusetts
now he had a real traumatic childhood um
i guess he had been like uh sexually and
emotionally abused by his dad as well as
like a bunch of other adults in his life
so he was kind of like [ __ ] up from
the get-go
and um he was also not really all that
great at school uh he had dyslexia so he
didn't really um you know he he would
didn't do that well in school and he
didn't really have that many friends uh
they thought he was a weirdo and creepy
and uh this is kind of [ __ ] up too and
like i said i don't know if this is true
necessarily but he got sent to like when
he was a teenager
he got sent to a school psychiatrist uh
for his weirdness and uh that
psychiatrist also ended up molesting him
so you know and abusing him so i don't
know like i said i don't know if that's
true or not but you know
so he also later got diagnosed with
hyperactivity
disorder
um you know so he was not really having
a good time
i guess
now so he pretty much turned to crime
very very early on uh he first started
out pretty small like um you know just
breaking into people's houses and
stealing [ __ ]
uh so
by the time he was 15 he was breaking
into people's houses
and
not only taking their [ __ ] while he was
in there but he was also
leaving stuff behind because he just
thought it was funny like he would go in
the house take people's stuff
and then he would like move things
around or like leave like creepy
messages and stuff like that so that
people would know that he had been in
there so he seemed to like get off on
having been in there and like having
people know that you know i mean like
playing mind games with them
now in 1986
is when
the [ __ ] that he's known for nowadays
like started to happen
he somehow got the phone number of
this other family this is the 80s so
it's like nobody had cell phones or
anything like that
so he gets this phone number from this
uh of a family that like lived in the
same area or the same street as him
um it could be that he had broken into
the house at some point and had gotten
the phone number then they don't really
know
now this house actually and it was
belong to um
like a family there was like a dad and
like two daughters and the daughters
were 15 and nine uh the daughter's names
were tina that was a 15 year old and
karen uh who was the nine-year-old the
bowen family
now danny calls up
tina the 15 year old now he's only 15 or
16 at this point too
so he kind of starts to like establish a
little bit of a little phone
relationship with tina like i said
they're kind of the same age it's not
like he's 40 or anything like that
now he basically tells her he's like oh
um i saw you at school and i thought you
were cute and a friend of yours gave me
your phone number that's what he said
he also totally lied about what he
looked like he said that he was this
role like it's like a jock type he was
wrong he was blonde and athletic and
blah blah and he also lived in the area
so tina and daniel like talk on the
phone and like they're kind of hitting
it off you know what i mean
and so at one point like they after they
have like several conversations like he
kind of asked her to go out on a date
and she says yes she thinks that they're
you know she thinks it's a mutual friend
you know what i mean
so he turns up
at the bowen's house
and tina immediately sees this is not
the person that this he hasn't uh
described himself correctly or
accurately uh obviously
uh she said you know he described
himself as like this blonde athletic
jock dude uh but no he's this greasy
dark-haired
sloppy-looking [ __ ]
um who kind of looked like i don't know
but i've seen pictures of him he doesn't
look that bad but
i mean he's not ugly but
yeah he didn't look like he said he
looked like
so tina's just kind of like what the
[ __ ] but okay she already agreed to go
on a date with them so they go to this
like fair in town or whatever
now she's there for about an hour and
then she's like that's enough of this
[ __ ] and so she's basically like uh yeah
i gotta go home i gotta throw up or wash
my hair or something like that she makes
some excuses and takes off
now
during this date
daniel discovered that tina and her
sister karen
that their mom had recently died of
cancer which is why they only lived with
their dad
now daniel
asked a whole bunch of
questions about the kid like he was
super interested which like i said a
little bit of a red flag
he kept like asking her questions about
um
you know how did you feel when she died
and like how much did she suffer before
she died is [ __ ] like that like weird
ass questions like that which is
probably why after an hour she's like
yeah i'm out of here this is like
[ __ ] weird and like i said this was
the 80s so it's like people had i guess
they did the red flags weren't quite as
like
you know what i mean you'd let it like a
lot more slime back then like nowadays
like immediately people be like nope and
they just like run the other way but she
was just like an hour just like he's
asking like all these [ __ ] weird ass
questions
now
so okay so what happens that i guess
like i don't know if he called her again
after that but she's like yeah i don't
think i'm gonna be stealing c in that
dude anymore because he's a [ __ ]
weirdo
now it so happened coincidentally this
is so [ __ ] weird you guys
like if it made this into a horror movie
nobody believe it
so
completely coincidentally
tina and her nine-year-old sister
they decide that they're going to try to
talk to their dead mom
by doing a seance in the basement
just
you know like that's something that kids
would do like back in the 80s
so
they do the seance and like nothing
immediately happens but then
they start hearing this knocking against
their bedroom walls while they're
sleeping
and the first thing they think is like
holy [ __ ] like the seance like that's
our mom like talking to holy holy crap
like she's communicating
and this is like the middle of the night
like it's a it wasn't in the middle of
the seance it was like later on like
after the sentence was over like after
they'd gone to sleep then they started
hearing like this knocking on the walls
and they thought that their mom was like
communicating with them so [ __ ] up
it's so [ __ ] up
so
they get up and then they start talking
to this like thinking it's their mom
like asking her questions it's like hey
you know one knock for a yes and two for
no [ __ ] like that
um
so yeah they really thought they were
talking to the mom
and this went on for a couple of
evenings
um
until the knocking got so bad that it
started like interrupting their slowly
kept like waking them up
now also around this time period uh
objects in the house started
disappearing
like uh for example there would be some
stuff like on a table and then like the
next morning it'd be like all over the
floor
um furniture would be moved from one
side of the room to the other [ __ ] like
that
now karen and tina like i said being
kids in the 80s
they didn't immediately like think oh
there's somebody in the house they
thought
well maybe maybe what we were talking to
wasn't our mom maybe it was a demon
um and it's like moving [ __ ] around and
we're in [ __ ] trouble
now the dad frank
he just thinks that the two girls are
[ __ ] around and he wants him to knock
it off he's like why just like why are
you little brats like [ __ ] moving all
this furniture around and [ __ ] the
house up you guys are doing it and
they're like no seriously we did a
seance and we think we summoned a demon
and now there's like all this [ __ ] like
moving around the house and [ __ ] like
that but frank is like absolutely not
i'm not believing that kind of crap
um he's like you know your mother just
died i understand you're going through
some [ __ ] but it's like please knock it
off
now one night in early 1987 the knocking
had started
when karen and tina were uh in the front
room
and like i said at this point the
knocking on the walls just it happened
like so much that it was just like
driving them crazy like pretty much
because it was like waking them up they
couldn't get any sleep and [ __ ] like
that
but this particular evening i guess
because they were in a different room
they realized that the knocking was
actually not coming from the walls but
it was actually coming from the basement
so the two girls i'm presuming that the
dad wasn't home at the time so the two
girls they go in the kitchen and they
get a knife
and they go they're pretty brave i mean
you got to say and they go creeping down
to the [ __ ] basement with a knife 15
year old girl and a 9 year old girl
they go down there
and
written on
the basement wall in what appeared to be
blood
was something that said i'm in your room
come and find me
on the [ __ ] wall
so the girls
intelligently not like people in a
horror movie just said [ __ ] that and ran
out of the [ __ ] house and went to the
neighbor's house
uh so they wait for their dad to come
home and they're like holy [ __ ] dad go
down in the [ __ ] basement and check
that [ __ ] out
so the dad again thinking that the girls
are just like [ __ ] around or like
acting out because their mom died or
something like that
um
he's like you little [ __ ] need to go
to like counseling because you're having
some problems
now
i guess everything was like kind of
chill for like a few weeks
but then
kind of a similar thing happened uh but
weirder
so the girls hear knocking sounds again
like a couple weeks later but this time
the knocking was coming from behind
tina's bedroom wall
now at this point like the girls go back
down to the basement and this time there
was another message
written there and it said i'm back find
me if you can written on the wall in
like red what looked like blood
it wasn't spoiler alert but it looked
like blood
so
at this point they tell their dad again
their dad is just kind of like yeah you
girls are just like being you guys need
to knock this [ __ ] off um because they
had again run to a neighbor's house and
called him and he marches in there and
he's like look nobody's in here
but what ended up happening was that
this time when frank the dad goes into
the house
he sees
more [ __ ] than what the girls what he
had seen like originally you know what i
mean
so
he's like okay now he finally believes
it's maybe there's somebody else in here
so he goes into tina's room
now
on the wall in tina's room
there was something had been painted on
the wall again like in red and it said
marry me
on the wall
then on the other side of the room
like frank turns around
and there's a boy standing there
who is wearing the dead mom's clothes
like a wig and makeup and everything
and he's standing there with a [ __ ]
hatchet and like i said it's like a
[ __ ] horror movie
and this kid like i said was daniel
laplante
now
frank the dad like jumps on the kid but
you know the kid like kind of like
managed to like wriggle away
and
frank was just kind of like where the
[ __ ] did that little brat go you know
what i mean like he couldn't figure out
where he'd gone to so he calls the cops
and the cops discovered
that um
well first thing they discovered was
that the messages that were that was
actually ketchup it wasn't blood
um but so the cops like search the house
and they found a crawl space behind a
cupboard which was uh built into the
wall of tina's bedroom
and when they opened this little hatch
up
daniel was in there like curled up in
there so he'd been living in their house
all this time
so they pull them out the crawl space
and put them and place them under arrest
obviously
now after they arrested him they
searched the rest of the house
now
they found out that this little
[ __ ] had been living inside the
walls down in the basement [ __ ] like
that what he had done was that the
passageway like the little cupboard that
they found him in he had actually kind
of like tunneled around to like other
areas of the house and he had like
drilled out some peepholes
um so he could like watch tina
and [ __ ] like that
and obviously he had been pretending to
be the ghost of their mom like just to
[ __ ] with them because that's kind of
what he did
and
that's when he was actually planning on
the reason that he was wearing the mom's
clothes and like all that kind of stuff
and the wig and everything was because
he was gonna like freak him out by like
pretending to be the ghost of the mom
because this dude like had some issues
clearly
um and they don't know like because he
had a knife they're not really sure what
he was intending to do
um so
for the next year he actually got put in
juvie because like i said he was only 15
or 16 at the time so he was in juvie
until october of 1987 and then was
released now after he got released he
went back to like steel and [ __ ]
now
during one of the robberies that he
committed in november of 1987
he actually ended up stealing two
handguns from a neighbor's house and you
can probably know how this shit's gonna
go
so december 1st 1987
daniel breaks into another house like
around the same area of the gustafson
family which is about a half a mile away
from
you know the house from before
so he breaks in there and then he's kind
of confronted by one of the people who
lives in the house who was a pregnant
woman named priscilla gustafson who was
33 and she also had two little kids
named abigail and william
now
hours later when priscilla's husband
andrew came home
he comes home and he finds his wife
face down on the bed
uh she had been raped and shot multiple
times in the head at point blank range
uh they also found the two children of
five-year-old william who'd been drowned
in the upstairs bathtub
eight-year-old abigail had been drowned
in the downstairs bathtub so this
[ __ ]
daniel kid
had broken into another house like in
the same neighborhood
raped and killed a pregnant woman and
drowned two little children
so great great
um
so i don't really know like okay so
obviously he gets uh arrested they found
like a bunch of stuff like in the house
like restraints and [ __ ] like that what
they think
happened was that he broke into the
house for whatever reason
and held the victims at gunpoint and
then restrained them
uh killing the mom first because
obviously she was the biggest threat she
was an adult i mean like i said he was
just a teenager
now the authorities like pretty much
figured out immediately that this was
daniel laplante who had done this and
they couldn't find him at first though
so it's like they had to do like this
big manhunt
so
they actually what ended up happening
was that he went a couple towns over
and then broke into another house
and kidnapped a woman and took her car
now the woman actually escaped like got
away from jumped out of the car or
whatever um and then later on somebody
saw daniel la plant because obviously
his uh picture was all over the news by
this point because he was you know a
fugitive
so somebody saw it and reported it
so they actually found him
in a dumpster like he was hiding in
there like 48 hours after the manhunt
had started
and they actually found hair belonging
to abigail gustafson one of the little
kids that was drowned they found it on
his clothing which you know obviously
evidence that he had something to do
with the murder
so he actually got sentenced a year
after that he got sentenced to three
life sentences for the murder of the
gustafsson family
now he's in prison forever uh they're
never letting him out
and uh it's said that he doesn't really
show any remorse for his actions uh he
obviously has a lot of uh mental
disorders clearly
um
but he what he tried to do they said
from 1988 to 2014
he tried to sue
the courts a whole bunch of times for
violating his rights which is [ __ ]
rich okay
he says
one of the one of the lawsuits and this
just makes me want to punch him
one of the lawsuits is like oh well you
guys are violating my religious rights
because i'm a practicing satanist
and i required some materials in order
to carry out some satanic rights but you
guys wouldn't let me so yeah
i'm like get the [ __ ] out of here with
that oh my god i just want to punch you
right in the throat for that kind of
crap it's bad enough that you have to
like i said and i've said this before
look man it's bad enough if you're a
cereal kid's bad enough that you could
[ __ ] murder people in cold blood
that's bad enough okay you don't have to
like put the [ __ ] cherry on top of
the [ __ ] sunday by also being this
[ __ ] edge lordy [ __ ] that's
just kind of like you're denying my
rights i'm a satanist and i should be
allowed to just [ __ ] off with that just
[ __ ] off you know what i mean at least
have the decency to shut the [ __ ] up and
just be in prison just shut the [ __ ] up
and leave everybody else alone don't
come out and like run in your mouth god
damn it
you're just like compounding your error
you know what i mean you're never
getting out shut up so it's just kind of
like
okay so in 2017
the [ __ ] comes forward and he's
appealing for a reduced sentence so like
i said they gave him three life
sentences i don't think that any
possibility of parole
but he comes out and he this is the
quote that he said
i do not have the words to full i'm
trying to be sarcastic because i know he
doesn't mean it i do not have the words
to fully express my profound sorrow but
i'm truly sorry for the harm i have
caused for the from the very essence of
who i am from the depth of my soul i am
sorry
yeah right no you're not
so uh apparently they had like a a
couple psychiatrists um you know kind of
interview them and [ __ ] like that
they're like [ __ ] not sorry don't you
[ __ ] let him out so they didn't they
didn't uh so he's gonna be in the jail
the rest of his life and like i said he
went in when he was what like 16 17
something like that he wasn't he was
made for the outside world he's got to
be locked up that's yeah i mean the [ __ ]
that he was doing and i'm not saying i'm
not like
saying that it was right what happened
to him as a kid if all that [ __ ] that
happened when he was a kid like that he
got like sexually abused and all that so
that's [ __ ] up okay but
that doesn't really excuse the [ __ ] that
you do like later on either you know
what i mean because a lot of people go
through like bad [ __ ] when they're kids
and it's bad whenever it happens to
anybody but that doesn't give you
license to go around [ __ ]
just doing what the [ __ ] you want you
know trust that dude that's what i'm
saying and i'm just
i you know at this point um
they're like they i mean the
psychiatrists that have like talked to
him have advised that please do not ever
let him out because he's the boy is not
right
so
you know what i mean uh the sad thing
about it is that
the um the husband of the pregnant woman
that got killed he actually died in
2014.
uh they said that on his deathbed
the last thing that he said before he
died was don't ever let him out
he should rot in prison yeah
and uh
so like if he if that was really his
last words that's hardcore
but you know what i mean but um i guess
they're never going to which like
rightfully so
and like i said i'm look if you didn't
do like violent crime or [ __ ] like that
i'm like a big advocate of like you know
don't lock people up for [ __ ] that's not
violent or anything but this
[ __ ] crazy this is exactly the
kind of person that they should never
ever ever let out because jesus christ
and i don't think they're ever going to
but yeah
okay so um do you want to go ahead and
shut it down you hungry at all
uh
a little bit i guess i got some more
pizza left if you want something yeah i
might as at least i'll have some okay
and uh but uh no uh the only other
[ __ ] thing i can say is that uh i was
talking about the chat with sly the only
other the only movie i could recommend
based on this would have been intruder
and intruder involves a [ __ ]
hiding in your house
okay i think like i said i think there
have been a lot of movies like that yeah
i got you know what i was thinking about
this and i wanted to bring this up i
don't know when who or when the term
frogging was coined for what this is
because the thing about it when we were
thinking about doing the show i said i
know there's a word i know they like did
like a neologism for that and i couldn't
like remember what it was and then i
looked it up i'm like frogging that's i
don't like that but because they're like
oh because they're like hopping from
place to place like a frog i'm like well
not really that's not usually what's
happening
and i was kind of like
surely they could think of a better more
sinister sounding word than that yeah i
mean that's just like a dumb who the
[ __ ] coined that all right sly said he
saw the uh the intruder [ __ ] sequel
uh trailer and says he lo he likes uh
what do you say he said uh i love
michael and dennis looks great wow yeah
we that was 2019 we saw that in the
theater uh at amc theaters
and for that year
there were a few good movies in 2019 but
for me
the ones that i didn't expect to really
like that one stuck out
you know some people said well man it's
kind of a tired idea and that's kind of
it didn't matter to me i had a good time
watching it you know and it was well i
mean you could argue that like
everything everything's done
everything's been done so it's just kind
of like all you have to look i don't i
don't care if it's been done just
entertain me talk about this makes you
want to go back and watch that movie i
definitely
i wanted to buy that on blu-ray after we
saw it and i never got around to it i
got a bla i want to buy that for my
collection but i got to see what the
prices are
fb 555 said uh unlawful entry with ray
liotta yeah that's another i didn't see
it i didn't see it rabbit ferris said uh
frog squat it's just a weirder version
of squatting so frogging probably still
could have played i yeah i know it's
like i get it i get like where the
nomenclature comes from but it's like i
don't know it seems like
i think the thing that makes me mad
about it is that it's not
one it's not entirely accurate and two
it doesn't sound sinister enough it
almost kind of like makes it sound like
funny and i'm just like look if some
[ __ ] was living in your attic
and you didn't know that then it's
absolutely not funny so it's like i kind
of feel like it should have like a
scarier name you know it's just like i
was kind of like
i don't know i'm like can we maybe do
something remember that movie we
reviewed not too long ago with creepy
ass klaus kinski in it called
i was just kind of like could we like
maybe could we call it like kinskiing or
i don't know
something like that because it's like
something that would like
kind of
kind of convey the gravitas of the
situation like how [ __ ] horrifying it
would be because frogging just sounds
kind of cute you know what i mean it's
like oh frogs i like frogs but it
doesn't sound scary
now if klaus kitsky was like looking
through my vents yeah that would be
scary
if you guys didn't see crawlspace we
reviewed that movie not too long ago
there well i think there's more than i
think there's more than one but we call
crawlspace actually
but there was one with klaus kenski that
we talked about
and uh
i'm talking this live
yeah john gore said i know the clouds
can't get crawl space from 85. yeah we
reviewed it
probably like a couple months ago i want
to say yeah
did you did we review it or did just i
really would clock crawl space maybe i
maybe i just you wouldn't i think i just
reviewed it i wanted to see it again i
think i think i just heard she saw
without me
that was one of the ones that i wanted
to see again well you didn't tell me
yeah that you didn't tell me yeah
because i just watched it because i felt
like watching it and then i just made a
reputation i've seen that video i've
already seen it two or three times yeah
i saw it when i was just kidding that's
a weird ass [ __ ] klaus kinski [ __ ]
see i would argue that having klaus
kinski living in your crawlspace would
be even scarier than having gary
and your clowns
[Laughter]
daughter raping ass up in your [ __ ]
uh [ __ ]
crawl space up in your house
now see that would be a good topic for
discussion who would be the creepiest
worst person to be living in your attic
without you knowing about it i mean i
could think of lots of people yeah i saw
that [ __ ] said crawl space is creepy
yeah and klaus
reportedly
allegedly klaus was [ __ ] doing his
older daughter
not natasha but the other one
she came in and he's just like horrible
did that move he was a crazy person he
was [ __ ] crazy yeah everybody knows
he was he's [ __ ] crazy
yeah
i mean the whole
i
um i still want to watch that
documentary yeah my best fiend yeah
about verner herzog and yeah and him and
class can't keep there's some kind of uh
magnetic about those guys verna herzog
was not a crazy person though i think he
was actually just he was just
professional
klaus kinsey was [ __ ] crazy you know
yeah he was [ __ ] crazy i mean werner
kept working with him and they were kind
of friends sort of but it's just kind of
like he was almost kind of like his muse
in a [ __ ] up way yeah but i think he
absolutely knew that he was crazy and he
was like super super difficult
to work with too because he was crazy
yeah
so
yes i didn't know this what the [ __ ]
class was a nut yeah
evidently according according to his
oldest daughter i've heard something i
don't remember her name but evidently he
had kind of kind of trained her to be
his slave
like a sex slave
i could see that yeah weird just from
the roles that he's been he's like he
seems and i like a lot of movies he's in
but i think like most of the movies that
he's in that are good are playing on his
natural
creepiness
whenever he's in a movie and they try to
make him like a normal person i'm like
please don't do that there's no way that
like klaus kinski could act like a
normal person he's just like he can't do
it yeah he can't do it and i remember
being a kid watching cat people [ __ ]
with his daughter natasha kinski she was
just cute as [ __ ] man
i [ __ ] i hope that i don't want to
say you know i hope that she [ __ ]
kind of escaped that fate you know what
i mean because
their dab is [ __ ] crazy i hate to say
a focus at all on her uh her older
sister but
uh
somebody should have [ __ ] arrested
that dude but nobody knew
that's some weird [ __ ] and that's kind
of the [ __ ] up thing is like i think a
lot of that was going on back then and
it's just
it's not like now where it would get
reported it's like back then it's like a
lot of times it was just kind of swept
under the rug and not and not always
like it wasn't always sexual abuse but
sometimes it was like physical abuse
yeah like you'd kind of like you know
smack your kids around or your wife or
something like that no one really did
that much about it or took it like all
that and if you were a famous artistic
[ __ ] who had a bunch of pull you
could get away with stuff
well it was just like anything else
if you had money or were famous i mean
you can always get away with [ __ ] that
regular ass [ __ ] are not
couldn't get away with
because people think well when you're
famous people think they know you so
they're like oh well you know okay he's
okay he would never do anything like
that i'm like yeah but you don't know
that person yeah actually even people
you know can be doing all kind of like
nefarious [ __ ] and you don't know about
it right
you we hear that all the time it's like
look people
btk had a [ __ ] wife and kids they
didn't know they didn't know what he was
doing no and he'd been doing that [ __ ]
for years
sarah ridgeway was going out
screwing dead and rotten hookers they've
been rotting for [ __ ] weeks and then
you go back to his wife and the wife
didn't
with all that stink on him he jumped
down into water and get it all off of
him and then [ __ ] get dressed again
that nasty little [ __ ] that's what i'm
saying so you never know like even if
it's i mean much less of being famous
people but it's like even people you
know that you think that you know like
famous like you know people you've been
married to or like in a relationship
they could be doing all kind of [ __ ]
that you don't know about and here's the
weirdest thing about [ __ ] gary
ridgeway the cop can't trust nobody i'm
saying here's
gary woodrow is a weak little man all
right he's just a weak little [ __ ]
deemed demonic little man
the cops asked him this is but she had
been like but you went back and had sex
with her yeah
but she had been dead for weeks he's
like yeah yeah
and and they were like
why are you having sex why did you have
sex with uh the dead ones you know for
weeks and he was like well because it
was free
because it was free
further right because it was free for
the record that's what tom says about
why he puts jelly and hot sauce on his
biscuit at waffle house it's free
because it's free but it's that's not
what you say about dead hookers yeah
yeah yeah that's just yeah you put hot
sauce and jelly on your [ __ ] on your
face
your sausage biscuit
because it's free and it tastes good you
don't screw a [ __ ] hooker that's been
dead two weeks in the [ __ ] summer
heat because it's free
what the [ __ ] you talking about dude i
mean they have
i'm sorry but they have sex toys are is
he not aware
they're very he's my in his mind they're
very easy to get to like you know
they're not expensive
yeah you can get even nowadays they have
ones that are like super realistic
yeah you know
yeah sly is talking about patty duke and
her her situation her dad yeah you never
would have suspected back then that
patty duke she was like little miss
america back in the 50s that's what i'm
saying well and her dad was tearing it
up that's what i said well like a lot of
and particularly back then because it
was very very important to like maintain
this kind of image
um which you know like i'm really glad
those days are gone honestly like i
would rather have people like just give
like too much information and [ __ ] but
like back then like nobody talked about
it like all kind of like i wouldn't have
believed you
that's what i'm saying
and the reason they wouldn't have
believed you is because nobody talked
about it they didn't think it was
possible right
and it's like that's [ __ ] up that's
[ __ ] up like keeping everything under
wraps like that so that's what i'm
saying like a lot of people that grew up
in that era
probably had all kind of [ __ ] up [ __ ]
happening but you but you didn't talk
about it my grandmother used to say
stuff like that she's like oh stuff like
that was going on but we just didn't
talk about it that's what she said slide
slide slides going that's right it's
free he's talking about putting putting
jelly on the tots and jim's right that's
right that's right sly you have to
understand something
it's not that you're black sly it's that
you're southern because southerners do
that to [ __ ] all come we're going to
put the [ __ ] jelly and the [ __ ]
hot sauce on well it's just all there
right there like you might as well it's
right there they call it up north they
call it soul food we just call it food
here what the [ __ ] you talking about
[ __ ] greens [ __ ]
you know [ __ ]
[ __ ]
country gravy
hell yeah [ __ ] you know what i mean
it's not soul food here it's just food
that's how we eat
up north they call it soul food it's
[ __ ] funny
although i think at this point like i
said i think i understand
um i think everybody is just kind of
like well [ __ ] man i was watching an
episode of the new series season of
masterchef
and they were do their whole challenge
which i was thinking this would probably
be really hard but they had to do a
fusion dish with southern food they all
had to do southern food but then they
had to mix it with
another country's cuisine that they just
like picked out of a globe or something
so it's like so you had to do like
fusion for example like of southern food
and like japanese food or like southern
food and thai food or something like
that some of them were uh disasters but
a lot of them turned out really good i
think the guy that won was like southern
food and jamaican food which like i said
seemed
that seemed a little bit easy
but because it's not really that far
apart but not that far apart really
that's what i'm saying we uh [ __ ] we
go down to sanford and you can get
[ __ ] soul food restaurant and [ __ ]
african
african nigerian food
and uh they're real similar and it uh
that's what i'm saying it's not math no
real similar
um
what was i gonna say about that [ __ ]
[ __ ] um go you can go on youtube and
go look up thomas payne
thomas payne he's a [ __ ] famous
uh black historian american historian
and he'll [ __ ] just go on about
to go on about how there wasn't any
difference really between black and
white southerners black people can move
north for many generations but they're
still southerners and the way that they
act and what they eat and [ __ ] how
they talk and
and you all got that from us and it all
kind of came from [ __ ] tribal ireland
mixed in with [ __ ] haiti and stuff
it's all kind of just mixed together
but um
we got real culture
you know oh i mean i'd say that because
you know i mean i'm ethnocentric but
[ __ ] you because they got up north it's
a little bit more scandinavian and more
more british style and
you have italians and stuff but
in the south it's just kind of
scottish irish germanic and african and
it's all just kind of blended together
into one thing you know there were
differences but they weren't very big
and thomas peen will tell you where it
all comes from
danny rowling said for tom and jenny out
of all these frogging hiders you've
mentioned which one had the best shelter
set up most of them weren't really that
good because i think most of them
weren't really that long term
so i will say that the guy that was
secretly living in the house with all
the other college students like in ohio
because he had an actual kind of room
that sort of had a quasi bed and a
bathroom even though the bathroom
apparently didn't work all that well uh
so he actually had sort of like a room
even though it was just like closet size
the rest of them it was either like a
crawl space or they were just like
sleeping under insulation or like under
some stolen jackets and stuff like that
in a [ __ ] attic which i'm sure wasn't
really that great so i'm gonna say it
was the
university of ohio guy jeremy that was
his name was it thomas payne
i don't know
uh hold on zach said now i'm trying to
imagine what cajun style sushi would be
like and not gonna lie it actually
sounds kind of good i was actually
really curious i was glad that they
actually did that challenge because i'm
sitting there going
man that some of the countries they came
up with i was like how would you [ __ ]
do that like some of them it seemed like
kind of easy like i said like southern
food and jamaican food that doesn't seem
like that much of a stretch um and some
of the other ones like i think the ones
that won
or the ones that were the top ones were
the southern and jamaican southern and
spain
and
i think the girl that did southern food
would cross with tai which actually came
out like strangely good or no maybe hers
didn't [ __ ] i don't know but it was
something like that but i don't remember
what oh oh yeah no it wasn't thomas paid
his name is thomas sowell
that's him right there thomas soul
s-o-w-e-l-l
thomas payne was a uh from the 1700's
thomas sold listen to him
he'll tell you all about it
yeah i mean thomas paine was the guy
yeah yeah yeah yeah
i was somebody completely different
somebody mentioned him earlier on today
when i was talking about revolutionary
stuff somebody mentioned that it was
thomas soule
s-o-w-e-l-l so we went from talking
about banging dead hookers to talking
about getting jelly on yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah and then
i guess that was my fault that time
because that's because that's what you
always said about like putting stuff on
your yeah food at waffle house was
because it was free i was like oh yeah
that's what gary ridgeway said yeah
you can go right there the origin of
redneck culture okay he does things on
that and everything you'll you'll see
you'll see
yeah
but yeah but what i was saying was that
i do kind of feel like those because we
were talking about klaus kanski i do
kind of feel like there was like so much
[ __ ] up [ __ ] like happening
in families like back then
but
you just didn't talk about it so i'm
just like really glad that we've gotten
past that point where now it's like okay
to talk about it
um
because i kind of feel like for a long
time people just like [ __ ] horrible [ __ ]
happened and that's why everybody was so
[ __ ] up man
i'm not saying people are [ __ ] up
nowadays of course they are but
it's worse if
you had all this [ __ ]
if you had grown up and were like
sexually abused for example
and
nobody talked about that kind of stuff
or you didn't have anybody that you
could tell about it or you didn't like
you couldn't go to like a therapist and
like get your feelings out of it or
anything like that you just had to like
pretend everything was fine because you
had to like keep up appearances and
stuff
i mean i can't imagine
what that would do to you over years and
years of like trying to like pretend
like everything was normal so like i
said that is like completely [ __ ] up
and i'm just like really glad that like
we're not expecting people to do that
anymore to a large extent because that's
messed up it's like totally not healthy
um let's see
yeah they were talking about that [ __ ]
you are right
because you've gotten all acquired i'm
drunk you've gone all the way i'm very
drunk
are you really yeah yeah are you gonna
pee on the floor no i'm not gonna get
i'm not gonna pee on the floor in my
sleep i never did pee on the floor
i was dreaming that i was peeing on the
floor but you know that i'm gonna keep
bringing that up there yeah
yeah but that was the first time i
thought yeah had you not stopped me it
might have happened that's what i'm
saying uh yeah it might have happened
but like i said i don't know how long
you were standing there i i think i was
standing there a long time but [ __ ] i
don't know though because my spidey
spent senses like woke me up and i was
just kind of like ooh there's some weird
[ __ ] going on in here
yeah that's weird
i had been slamming all those [ __ ]
mojitos at the [ __ ] club
which we got to go to on friday i'm
looking forward to friday that's right
yeah friday's momentum yeah so yeah
we're gonna do obviously we're gonna do
the sidetrack show on friday but we're
gonna be going out afterwards so we
can't get too drunk on the show because
we gotta go out afterwards
and hopefully
i don't have to drive home like i did
last time
because
like i said i haven't seen you that
drunk in a long time and they don't even
have lick real liquor at that please no
he got that [ __ ] up on like beer and
those little
those [ __ ]
bacardi mojito cans but i was thinking
because he's just like oh there's hardly
any alcohol
i don't even know him i was slamming it
like it was water and it's been
[ __ ] he was like [ __ ] me up
incoherent like at the end of the night
yeah yeah that's right that's right the
that's right sly he's he was a yale
professor
yeah that's good so uh uh thomas soul
he'll tell you the truth about [ __ ]
where all this [ __ ] came from uh
african-american culture is southern
and it was in it was
related to just redneck culture and then
it says where that comes from and they
were not
it was not a culture based upon legalism
it was based upon honor
you pissed a [ __ ] off they came
after you it was tribal
and he explains all of it
and the the same comet
mentality the same diet the same it's
the same culture and you trace it back
to basically
primeval scotland and ireland it's a lot
where a lot came from it wasn't africa
it's just that y'all was with us down
there and we were a bad influence on
black people black people picked it up
real quick
even the
ebonics is [ __ ]
southern
southern people talk like that didn't
matter what color they were
now there were differences between the
two but it was that same basic version
in english and it had a
scottish irish germanic root to it
because this the southern states
especially mississippi alabama
were kind of like south africa of the
united states
but seoul will tell you all about it
where it all came from and then after
the war black people moved north taking
it with them as they went
and northerners couldn't deal with that
[ __ ] but they couldn't deal with us down
here either
it's always been a rebel culture
a culture of defiance
thank you bryce thank you just tuned in
we'll have to listen to the rest later
this year
topic yeah we it's in it's going to be
in two parts because uh we did like an
hour or so the first show and then our
power went out because it was a bad
storm so we had to like start another
one so it'll be like in two parts uh sly
asks what's a mojito a mojito is a
[ __ ] great drink that actually comes
from puerto rico
uh isn't it right puerto rico right i
thought it was cuban
uh no i think it's puerto rican
we're somewhere around that i don't know
it's one of the islands off the coast of
florida here
it's
a light drink
um it's very refreshing it's very
refreshing very refreshing um it's
rum
and
sugar
and lemon juice
in
soda water
with with uh
lime
and mint and mint
but
in puerto rico it's not mint it's just
an herb that's like mint
here we use mint
think of a lemony minty sprite
kind of like that
but with ramen rum in it right it's real
good they are good they're it's a good
summer drink yeah they're not real
strong you can uh drink a lot of them
and you can drink them fast
mojito
and we and
i mean barbarella which like i said when
it was downtown they obviously had like
the full liquor license so we could get
like cocktails and stuff but the place
they moved to
they only have like the canned stuff so
you can get like a canned mojito like
the bacardi has one which are actually
like pretty good i don't mind that but
like i said they're only like five
percent alcohol zach says i wish there
were more alcoholic drinks i could get
into i usually find them either too
bitter or too sweet and always
disgusting
i'm not really i'm not really sure how
to help you i don't know um
i'm just a big i like
screwdrivers which is just vodka and
orange juice
i like
kind of some i like some flavored vodkas
which i really like like cherry
vodka and sprite i really like that
combo
um i like jack and coke sometimes i like
gin and tonic sometimes although those
are very very
start they're very tart so i can only
drink like one or two of those and then
i'm like yeah i'm gonna barf if i drink
any more of these because they're very
acidic
but
i don't really know like a lot of the
drinks that i like are kind of sweet i
like kind of sweeter ones more than yeah
kind of bitter ones
some of the drinks we like at the club i
used to really like um
red deaths but what the [ __ ] in those
everything
that was the red death was you look at
it it tastes like fruit tastes like
fruit punch but it is nothing no mixer
in there it's all alcohol
and it's all the alcohol it's all of it
it's like vodka rum yeah there might be
tequila is there it's kind of like long
island iced tea where it doesn't taste
like there's alcohol in it but it's
almost all out
it's like a magic trick
yeah you drink four three of those and
you're [ __ ] fl and you're just like
laying there going
the only thing in there but it doesn't
taste like alcohol the only thing that
was not alcohol and that was grenadine
syrup they put a little bit of gravy
everything else was some kind of alcohol
yikes
yeah they make a lot of drinks like that
there's one called um
the red death is what i usually get
because it's red obviously but they have
one called what's the melon one
that one was called uh liquid marijuana
liquid marijuana liquid marijuana that's
another one it's kind of like a long
long island ice but it has it has like
melon liqueur in it yeah and it tastes
you would never think that you would
think it was a weak drink everything in
there is some kind of hard liquor
so yeah you drink like two of those and
you are [ __ ] up you're [ __ ] up it's
all hard
with maybe like a few liqueurs like one
of them i think might
be midori
yeah and uh but the rest of it
yeah like i said there's a whole there's
a tokyo tea which is also kind of green
yeah it's green and it tastes like
japanese sweet green tea like green tea
but it's like a it's like a it's like a
long island iced tea it's all hard
liquor and those things will put you
under the [ __ ] table because you can
drink them fast they're sweet you go
there's nothing in this no that's all
alcohol
yeah i've gotten in trouble yeah and
even though like i know because there's
i kind of feel like there's a whole sub
genre of cocktails
that their whole existence is like
supposed to fool you yeah they're like
it's it doesn't taste like an alcoholic
drink necessarily like i said like a red
death kind of just tastes like fruit
punch
but
it's like four or five different
alcohols with just like a tiny bit of
like juice and liqueur in it
but that tiny bit of juice and liqueur
like negates all of the other alcohol so
you can drink it and it doesn't really
taste like alcohol but like i said you
drink like two of them like two of like
a double size and you are completely
completely [ __ ] up yeah completely
[ __ ] up
so
they kind of fool you like that
uh peach schnapps with oj yeah that's
pretty good
uh sly says i like cherry and vodka yeah
i honestly like a lot of the flavored
vodkas
not so much i mean i like the cherry
ones um the grapefruit one is good
uh i even like the lemon one although
you gotta watch because like i said
that's also very tart
and if i drink too many like real tart
things it'll kind of make me feel
nauseated but
you know what i mean
uh so i said my ex loved uh long island
iced tea yeah
yeah those things will put you under the
[ __ ] table they will yeah yeah
because like i said it's just it seems
like
you're like oh there's nothing do this
yeah i think that's what gets you in
trouble because it doesn't taste like
right it's that strong but it is it's
absolutely like wasted it's all alcohol
well danny rowling said sex on the beach
is the manliest of all men yeah that's
the man
of course it is those are actually
pretty good actually man there's been
[ __ ] around here they'll serve some
shots that'll [ __ ] put you under the
table
like uh snickerdoodles [ __ ] um yeah
those are good uh what was the other one
the uh the oatmeal cookies
that was actually my favorite shop
the oatmeal cookie shot and the lemon
drop shot probably my favorite ones yeah
whenever somebody offered because every
now and then they go shots shots
so usually i'd be like oatmeal cookie or
lemon drop yeah those are my two
favorite ones oatmeal cookie was like
rumchata and fireball and it's bailey's
and bailey's and bailey's and it tastes
just like it tastes just like an oatmeal
cookie yeah man those things are good an
oatmeal cookie that will make you pass
out yeah
because they start handing those things
out when you're already trashed
you're already trying to see that was
the problem it's just that you know and
i'm not averse to like having people buy
me shots hey i will take free alcohol
any day yeah but it's [ __ ] wonderful
but by the time yeah by the time that
everybody's getting all like [ __ ]
generous with it yeah i'm like look i've
already had way too much liquor by this
point and it's like i'm
can't even see at this point and now
y'all are buying me more and i feel bad
like turning it down yeah and that's
snickerdoodles was [ __ ] something
like rumshada and and fireball
yeah because the snickerdoodle cinnamon
cinnamon yeah because the snickerdoodle
is has as uh like a cinnamon
right
yeah i've made snickerdoodles before yes
they're they're not super strong but
they're like a cinnamony kind of like
soft kind of cookie they're really good
snickerdoodles
alaskan pipeline shots are good i don't
think i've ever had one
we might have it under a different name
all right i'm looking to see if there's
anything else that has to be
i love the cookies i always have since i
was a kid yeah but there is a
snickerdoodle shot it's a snickerdoodle
shot yeah i'm not real into fireball
though like i said it
it's good as a mixer i like cinnamon as
a concept like i'll eat cinnamon toast
all day long but fireball yeah and
anything that's like cinnamon flavored
like fireball or red hots or anything
like that just gives me like immediate
heartburn yeah
sit like right like cinnamon
if i eat cinnamon toast i don't get
heartburn but anything that's like
cinnamon flavored yeah burn so yeah all
right let's go ahead and shut it down
slide go ahead and watch intruder
intruder you'll like that [ __ ]
yeah i'm [ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up i'm gonna
have to start making this something to
eat go ahead shut it down danny said one
more case i don't have any more though
we don't have any more i mean i did so
many i did so many wait how many was it
like five six five six of them
no i did more than five because i had
five to start with i think i actually
did like nine or ten to be honest
you know what i mean all right so
we're gonna be back on friday night
doing our side track show like i said
we're not gonna try to not get too
[ __ ] up on the friday night show
because we got to go to memento mori
afterwards afterwards we're gonna be
partying we're gonna go to the club so
we're gonna pre-party and then we
probably should start it maybe a little
bit early and we'll we'll go light
on drinking because [ __ ] i don't know
we'll talk about it we'll talk about it
because like i said
and i'm still gonna bring it up like
last time we went to barbarella which is
where menta mori is i'm trying to
[ __ ] piss on [ __ ]
you're trying to pee on the floor and
walk around the house [ __ ] asleep and i
had to drive and i was not happy about
it because i had to take the [ __ ]
boots off because i can't drive in those
boots
i learned respect for the [ __ ]
bacardi [ __ ] uh
respect the canned bacardi
five percent alcohol five because if you
basically think well see that's the
thing it's just kind of like this is
just kind of like the same thing you
don't want to get a fight with like some
[ __ ] that's like this little
skinny oh that he's not gonna do
anything right and then like he just
comes in like under your defenses and
like punches you in the nuts or some
[ __ ] like that that was kind of what
happened
you're like this shit's so weak
how could this possibly bring down
the great thomas ross and then like at
the end of the night you were just like
yelling and waving your hands around and
people were like please jenny tell me
i had i had the cute she mails trying to
pull me into the men's room that's what
i mean that you're having like you're
having like you know uh
beautiful trans women trying to [ __ ]
pulling you into the bathroom trying to
blow yeah and trying to and trying to
yeah i showed pinterest i showed
pictures already
i showed pictures last time
it was all true it was crazy we don't
make [ __ ] up this [ __ ] is all true it is
uh all true i mean you make [ __ ] up but
i don't make [ __ ] up you generally say
if you're making [ __ ] yeah if i make
[ __ ] up i'll tell you i make it up but
no if it's real then i'll i'll tell you
i'll tell you this i've told you before
like we should probably write a book
we've had like some weird actions you
know when they're saying no trans women
aren't beautiful we talk about no there
was cute one i'm gonna show you oh [ __ ]
i don't have it on his phone she was
beautiful yeah she was cute i didn't
know he was ashley she's a little weird
though
i mean she well she was weird because
she was trying to like she was trying to
try to impress everybody well she was
trying to get me involved in like some
witchcraft ceremonies which i was just
kind of like okay cool and i was like
all right she was only 23. i know she
was very she was a baby
[Laughter]
but i didn't know i didn't know it was
girl obviously i didn't know it was i
thought it was a girl i didn't know it
was a like i said i didn't write no i
was just you told me later and i was
just like okay yeah and i was like
i got a girlfriend i can't do this [ __ ]
and she goes i know i love her i'm gonna
[ __ ] her too
and i that was mostly a bisexual and
she's like oh yeah yeah
and she's obviously i say you can't have
any of this until you okay through jenny
and she's like and she was like oh so i
got to go through channels so i can look
at the proper channels and it says yeah
you can go through proper channels and
just i'm going to talk to her and she
stormed off to come talk to you and then
[ __ ] her uh she never said this well
no her date grabbed her
what was his name
scott yeah scotty our friends got it
scottie grabbed her and said come on
let's go because [ __ ] she was trying
to run off of both of us
that happens a lot i tried to run over
both of us yes why did that happen
scotty had brought her out on a date
it was ridiculous we used to talk about
this a lot we're like i was ridiculous i
don't know what it is ridiculous about
maybe we're like a power cup maybe it's
just like people that we know but it's
just kind of like every time like
somebody brings some new virgin
[ __ ] yeah and all of a sudden to
the bar yeah and then all of it and then
they introduce them to us all of a
sudden
they just want to like come home and
like sleep in but yeah well that was i'm
not really sure why that is
we've had we've had it happen so many
times it can't be an accident yeah it
can't be an accident i mean i don't know
what kind of energy we're giving off i
don't know i'm not doing anything on
purpose we're just friendly to everybody
maybe that's what it
is toby he's like one of my best buddies
from the [ __ ] club he's a leather
daddy he's [ __ ] power top
leather he's daddy alpha gays like he's
right
he's my boy we've known him for about 10
years okay i've shown all kinds of
pictures of him all these [ __ ] women
loving on this dude he's a [ __ ]
handsome man
he shows up with some young dude that he
picked up off the internet
and i'm talking to both of them and then
this dude [ __ ] asking me everything
about anabolics and all kinds of working
out and the next thing you know this
dude [ __ ]
this dude's [ __ ] like i don't know
why i say he's in love with me but he's
just you know he won't talk to [ __ ]
toby anymore he wants to hang out with
me and toby gets mad
he's right here with that [ __ ] i said
toby what are you talking about man i'm
just talking and he thinks i stole his
boy
well we met him at the temple of mercy
show yeah yeah it's a temple of mercy
that's right you seem nice yeah
i mean you guys were mostly talking yeah
and jenny was right next to me he knows
like he knows that i got a girlfriend
and i'm straight and [ __ ] it's just i
mean i was right there just like
drinking water yeah it's just you know
you guys were talking about like you
know
steroids and stuff so i just kind of
tuned out because he's like he's like
yeah i'm gonna start working out i'm
gonna start doing this that says you you
turn out good this and that and this and
that and he goes i like muscle
and it says you need to get that [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ] and now now toby's under toby's
in training he got a trainer and
everything
so that's gonna work i thought he was
coming over here
no because it's too far for him he says
he's too far for a driver that's right
yeah he's got he's got a gym near his
house he [ __ ] i mean he literally he
got a trainer does he still live in that
house
uh uh i don't think i think it is that
one
okay
it's too far
that is fair too far if he still lives
where i think he lives then that yeah
that is right he's going into training
and that's like half an hour let's get
that [ __ ]
let me get that [ __ ] on hrt toby's as
cool as [ __ ]
he's cool as [ __ ] he's really cool yeah
yeah
[ __ ]
you know he's just like something
like something off a [ __ ] judas
priest album
he's just like a just a good dude he's
just a good dude he's a good dude to
like hang out with you know yeah he's
fun a lot of fun we've just known him
for so long
i [ __ ] try to talk him straight he
wouldn't go straight
he'd be out there [ __ ] death well
let me flip this around can anybody talk
you gay no they can't they can't see
that's what i mean
when i'm not doing that what i'm saying
is he's out there [ __ ] dancing and
these women are just [ __ ] dripping
off this dude
okay
and i said toby you got so much because
it's a man that can dance i guess so
it's a rare animal and i said toby you
got so much to offer like he's got
rhythm oh my gosh so how could you deny
it how can you deny this to these women
because i mean 95 of straight dudes
can't really dance i mean like not to be
an [ __ ] but they can't yeah he's like
he he's like i thought about it but it's
just not me and then i was like all
right that's what i mean okay
but what i don't understand when he gets
drunk he loves you
he loves you well i have to get they go
lesbian and [ __ ] i gotta [ __ ] step in
beside him it's like toby you you step
you're stepping down the line you get
into you're getting too [ __ ] heavy
with it you get into it he's like i
don't mean anything by it and he tried
to read it over
that [ __ ] tries to swoop you
away i know i know that
but i i understand i understand
y'all are y'all are girlfriends
well like i said he's a good dancer and
he and he like he he's all he likes to
dance with me he's he he's all man and
he'll do like sometimes he's [ __ ]
lovely he'll be dancing with me and
he'll be like worshiping and stuff he'll
like go down and i'm just like okay i'm
liking that that's cool yeah he'll start
worshiping and [ __ ]
and i'll be looking like that and he'll
look at me and [ __ ] go come on i'm
like all right he's trying to get me in
and i'm like you know
he's like yeah because that [ __ ] that
[ __ ] is trying to get bad just to try
to do something bad worship i'm into it
just how it
it's the kind of is we go to and we've
known these people for [ __ ] over a
decade and it's just you know i mean
they're like it's like you're related to
them it's a it's not the same well like
i said it's that's why we like it yeah
because we've known these people forever
and it's almost kind of like your family
but not but not like the shitty people
that you have to see it thanksgiving
right but that kind of thing family that
you actually like family yeah
it's like yeah because we've known each
other for so long
let's see uh wait
i thought i saw something danny rowling
said great show topic tonight you outdid
yourself jenny thank you it's a weird
topic man people living in your [ __ ]
house i didn't realize that it was that
common but the thing about it was that
when i was researching it
i was i mean
okay this is gonna like sound [ __ ] up
in a way i was glad to see that most of
the cases didn't end up in murder like
the last one did but
on the other hand i was like well this
is a topic and i want to like make a
show about it so i wanted to find like
some horrific [ __ ] because that's like
more entertaining you know i don't know
what that says about us as a culture but
i'm just you know i'm leaving that there
so most of the cases though
were pretty innocuous
i mean as far as that could be like
finding somebody like living your house
i'm not saying that's innocuous but i'm
just saying like no one got killed or
you know most of the time nothing got
stolen or anything like that
but
so i tried to find like some cases that
were
creepy
because some of the stuff some of the
cases that i read were like
yeah that'd be creepy but
nothing that bad really happened
so
i don't know
i mean i'm glad that like most of them
don't turn out badly but you know what i
mean
so let me see
sly says i knew if i had met you guys 40
years ago i believe who would have
clicked 40 years ago i've been 13.
40 years ago i would have been
10
no i was cool when i was 10. he's only
10 years older than us though see he's
acting like he's [ __ ] ag [ __ ] and
[ __ ]
you could come out of the club now
see it wouldn't make it would it would
be cool it wouldn't matter i mean no one
would we know people your age at the
[ __ ] club
you know
see that's what i'm saying you don't
gotta like
you don't gotta like do we know people
that are older than us right that's and
nobody bats an eye
nobody back yeah i'm 53 she's coming up
on 50 so we're not young
yeah yeah
we're old [ __ ] yeah we just
work out and do [ __ ] strange
chemicals
[Laughter]
well and i think that it's not just that
but it's just the fact that we don't let
this [ __ ] [ __ ] bog us down and yeah
and i think nowadays
like i said there's there's not really
the expectation i think back in the old
days like what they're like well i'm 40
now so i'm old that's it i'm good so i
gotta act like an old person and it's
just even when i was a teenager i was
like that's [ __ ] why
why can't i just like like what i like
forever it's like i don't really want to
like have to act like an old person
because other people think that i ought
to says i'm 62 [ __ ] we know [ __ ]
people your age at the club still
yeah there's people older than us yeah
they're older than us
they've been around forever
and they're having fun
and it's like i don't know it's that's
kind of the cool thing about it is that
it's
just like a weird thing to say but it's
like it's kind of like a safe space you
just go there and it's like even if
you're old and you dance kind of [ __ ]
up or everybody was like nah
they're having a good time whatever
whatever uncle danny was about 70.
i thought he was older than that maybe
oh yeah 72 73. i thought he was older
than that he partied until the day he
died next day uncle daddy didn't show up
and i found out he was in the hospital
and the next thing you know he was dead
man that [ __ ] was on all the
drugs he's on all the drugs let me show
you uncle danny we called him uncle
daddy because he was just everybody's uh
uncle
that dude was so cool his name was he
used to come yeah we needed to see him
yeah danny titley
we used to see him at ibarr
yeah every weekend actually it wasn't
just the weekends because a lot of times
when we would go during the week
sometimes he was there then too i think
he used to go every night and he was in
his 70s yeah
he was on
many many like illegal drugs and he has
see
he had a um a dialy
that yeah that too he had a drug in
or a diary in which he kept track of all
the drugs he was on yeah how much did i
take today of this and that and the
other yeah that's him that was danny
titley tattoo was so [ __ ] cool yeah
and he just came out all the time and he
was just
he was always having the best time he
was always so super upbeat and you can
see he's mutual friends with me and
jenny at the [ __ ] top
everybody knew davey
he just [ __ ] went to the hospital and
croaked
okay but [ __ ] man he was like out
dancing and like partying until pretty
much the last yeah
there he was
he was hilarious everybody knew that
yeah
he would say the craziest [ __ ] and like
to be honest like he was on something
all the time he was [ __ ] high so he's
[ __ ] high as [ __ ] like all the time
that's the club we're talking about he
would go there
look there's a saunder in there i was
gonna say this
he was just he was a kind of a
mixed kind of light-skinned black dude
who just [ __ ] everybody loved him
he'd show up
and he was just such a good dude he was
just so positive yeah and he was just
coming like i said he was high as [ __ ]
and a lot of times he would talk to you
and it's like you had no idea what the
[ __ ] he's talking about and he [ __ ]
start yelling and his [ __ ] false
teeth and [ __ ] just fall out
and put it back in
but then he didn't like gold music and
then he'd go out and dance yeah and he
was just having a good time like yeah
and he was the coolest maybe 75 yeah he
was in the 70s and he was [ __ ] he
partied until the day he died
yeah i mean he was out almost every
night yeah
and then like a couple nights were like
hey where's uncle danny we didn't see
you and then nobody knew where he was
like for a few days and then we found
out that he was in the hospital he loved
women there he there he is
hold on hold on hold on
what is that
he uncle daddy he [ __ ] loved women
he'd be talking man her ass is so tight
there he is
[Laughter]
he likes girls i kind of miss uncle dan
yeah he's been dead for he was a fixture
five or six years now it's been a while
yeah man he was a fixture yeah yeah
he's a [ __ ] trip he was [ __ ] great
he was a lawyer actually he was yeah he
was he was a retired retired he was a
retired lawyer he used to be a lawyer
yeah
he was super fun
he was super fun
and he knew all the [ __ ] and he he he
knew everything
he he liked [ __ ] blowfly
we see him he was there saturday nights
all the time so he was really into like
uh 80s new wave he would come on to
momento mori sometimes yeah like he was
like knew all the industrial music and
[ __ ] like that he knew everything yeah
but yeah he was like super cool
he would talk about politics and [ __ ]
but he was he
essentially came out until he got too
sick to come out anymore like i said he
was in his 70s
and
he says i feel you i feel too good
and he was he was like
he was kind of like an old he was kind
of like an old uh
blues musician
or yeah
that's what he reminded me of i did i
tell you what and then
yeah
i don't know what the [ __ ] you're saying
i'll tell you this isn't that happen
what would you say i can't understand
what you say i'll [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
like that he's exactly like that that
was a really good impression actually
yeah it's just i'll [ __ ] you i don't
tell you what that and i'll tell you
what role and then the next thing you
know he's coming in here in the city of
my friend
i don't know what the hell happened
yeah
he was like
that's exactly the way he like when he
would go like that i'd just be like yeah
that's right i was like yeah okay
just like i said
he was super high as [ __ ] he was high
well he was very honest though about
like i said he kept a diary he would
tell you all the drugs he took and he's
like and he would show you like if you
ask like what do you want tonight and
he's like well i took this
milligrams of this today yeah as many
milligrams
yesterday and today i'm on this and that
and then i'm gonna take lsd tomorrow and
the next day and i'm gonna take a little
bit of this and i'll take crack on it oh
i love crack and then the next thing you
know
yeah yeah yeah that's what he he liked
crack he liked everything
he didn't need to keep him running
he was funny though he's funny as [ __ ]
it was funny [ __ ] them cops they never
[ __ ] with me the cops never [ __ ] with me
he was like that's it yeah he is always
saying the cops never [ __ ] with me
well he didn't cause any trouble no no
no no he wasn't like i said he wasn't
violent he wasn't obnoxious he was just
like super friendly everybody knew him
and it's just kind of like
he was an old attorney yeah yeah
like i said no one's gonna [ __ ] with you
you can do all the drugs you want as
long as you're not causing any [ __ ]
problems and he was retired so he didn't
have to go to work or anything yeah he
just really really liked going out to
the clubs and dancing and taking drugs
and everybody knew him and it was just
kind of like he was having a good time
and everybody's like all right
yeah
he looks like a beat nick exactly he did
yeah yeah he did yeah he'd sit there and
smoke and pull the glasses off and this
and that and he was like an old beatnik
yeah
yeah murder hornet said shout out some
heroine today yeah i think he might have
said that at one point oh yeah
he had no
qualms about he took everything
i liked he said he never took molly and
i said no i never had my oh my great you
to put the dipping and then you smoke it
this is fantastic you tell you about how
great molly was
i liked it i never had like very close
track of everything yeah he had the
little book
about what he took yeah
he kept very close track of it i was
just like all right fair enough but yeah
we kind of miss him because like i said
he used to everybody knew him he was
like a fixture yeah downtown
yeah and then like uh
the owner of barbarellos was like what
happened to danny i haven't seen him in
a while and i said he's dead he's like
yeah i figured
i mean we kind of thought like after he
hadn't shown up for like a week or two
yeah we kind of figured that something
was wrong yeah because he used to come
there
pretty much every night kept asking
through there and then
through facebook and then all of a
sudden there was an announcement that
danny tilly had died yeah
okay i mean everybody kind of figured it
out because he used to like come there
all the time yeah so a lot of people
were asking like what the [ __ ] happened
then i think like his uh
you know his relatives came on and said
yeah we know a lot of people don't ask
him but yeah
so
but just like i said just goes to show
dude was in his 70s and he just [ __ ]
went out having a good time man what he
wanted to do
and he was always like always happy and
always positive he was just always
having a good time
so
i told tom many times i'm like that's
how i want to go out
just like
drunk maybe high
dancing to some [ __ ] and like not even
worry about how [ __ ] old i am
i just thought that was really cool i
just thought that was really cool but
you know what i mean
uh sly said that's me super friendly
retired and love people like you guys
yeah see that's what i mean you don't
gotta like just
nowadays you don't gotta be like an old
person like in the old days
it's okay it's okay
um murder hornet said i was friends with
a lawyer and years later i found i was
banging my girlfriend oh my goodness
okay
danny rowling said sounds like a raspy
pill cosby
yeah little
a little
yeah
tom does lots and lots of voices but
honestly the voice that he's doing for
uncle that for uncle danny that's pretty
much what he sounded like
i mean
almost spot on that's pretty much
exactly what he sounded like
and
you know i mean i would go to the club i
you know you guys know i'm
pretty deaf and especially if there's
like other noise like if there's really
loud music and if there's like lots of
other people talking
i cannot hear a goddamn word that you're
saying
so a lot of times like people want to
have these big in-depth discussions like
people have a couple of like drinks and
then they're just kind of like and they
want to talk about like all this deep
[ __ ] which is cool but i'm just kind of
like i really wish that i could hear a
single [ __ ] word you were saying
right now but i really really cannot and
but i feel too bad
i feel kind of bad just like saying hey
i can't hear what you're saying
so
a lot of times i'm just like yeah
whatever so i don't know like i don't
know if like at some point like i've
been talking like some people about some
really deep [ __ ] in a club and like they
told me some really [ __ ] up [ __ ] and i
was like yeah cool
i probably have at some point because i
couldn't hear what they were saying i
can't hear what they're saying
so you know
john gore said my theory on lawyers is
they see how [ __ ] up uh so much of
humanity is and it rubs off on them yeah
maybe murder hornet said check your
messages tom yeah you talk about how
[ __ ] huge my arms are he's getting
jealous yeah man we'll [ __ ] work out
man
don't just take [ __ ]
you gotta take [ __ ] and work out
all right we're gonna have some more
pizza yeah let's get some more [ __ ] shut
it down jenny shut it the [ __ ] down
we're gonna be we're going to be on
tomorrow and then no not tomorrow friday
oh that's what we're off tomorrow right
yeah and then just friday we'll be out
we'll be on friday friday after tomorrow
before we go out yeah and then we'll
party tomorrow i'm going to take the day
off so i can nap yeah and party with a
part of their [ __ ] party with us
tomorrow kind of early and then uh we'll
leave we gotta go to the club tomorrow
i mean but for that we really don't have
to leave until i don't think they're
dimitri told me that they're not opening
the doors until
10. it's okay so we don't actually have
we just can't even drink a whole lot we
can't drink a whole lot tomorrow already
because we're gonna actually have to
leave until 9 30. okay i'm just saying
okay i'm not saying like oh you can
drink as much as you want i'm just
saying
we don't actually have to leave until
night okay
yeah rebecca just got here no damn time
zones yeah it's time zone rebecca and
honestly it's gonna be
i'm warning people ahead of time it's
gonna be in two parts because we did
like about a little bit over an hour and
then our power went out because it was a
really bad storm so we had two parts so
we had to start over
so it's going to be like in two parts of
the show which we haven't done for a
long time because
we've had a good internet connection but
like i said our power went out because
it was storm but you know so all right
so we will be back friday evening for
the side track show hopefully you guys
had a good time tonight i had a good
time did you have a good time yep yeah
we all had a good time all right so we
will see you guys again friday night
thank you very much for dropping by
thank you for your super chats and we
will see you again on friday bye